two
it is it is man it is Wednesday
here is Ethan Klein July 20th
yeah dude
I'm growing my hair back people think
again sunshine we live in a society
we live in a society we live in a
society ow
wow some say the universe will end not
in a bang but a whimper
and in this case an ow ow
welcome everybody July 20th we are off
the rails thank you Zach
some say Zach is the uh
The Reincarnation of a Mozart
when it comes to chaos
um
it's not chaos it's beautiful Symphony
of uh well thank you
it's a cosmic Symphony
um we have a great show of course for a
change you know finally yeah finally a
good one here for you guys you know I
have a funny little note for y'all
um our La our episode on Monday
which for some reason keeps getting more
and more views I don't know if it's
because people keep checking back or if
people have found a way to watch it
because like
um Monday's episode has a million views
which is a lot for just one day or like
two days now yeah you've um but but the
problem is is that we got a copyright
claim on it from
lit oh [ __ ] bro can you believe us
[ __ ] yep dude we got claimed by let's
get restarted
they claimed us for that [ __ ] yep I was
like what I thought that song didn't
even exist with the let's get mental uh
uh what What's the neurodivergent yeah
let's get neurodivergent does it exist
or not how are you gonna claim me on
that [ __ ] uh what are we going to do
about it because we we played it a
little more than usual right then we did
let's get it started and here it's the
in here that got us because we've played
without the in here many many times in
the last couple weeks and as soon as we
did the in here that was that was enough
for them to uh claim us well we didn't
even play a like a lyric from the song
it was let's get restarted yeah no that
song doesn't exist technically no it
doesn't so
no it doesn't Zach but anyway
um
yeah you gotta love that that was a
three hour and 44 Minute Podcast it got
claimed for five seconds
uh and then when they claim it they turn
off
for some reason they turn off the ad
Revenue
and so we said okay let's snip it
you can dispute it or YouTube introduces
a new tool that allows you to cut out
the copyrighted
um bit and then they'll turn back on
monetization it's actually a really nice
tool the problem is what most of the
time it's nice
I think the problem is is that our
videos are so long I don't think many
people upload four hour long videos to
YouTube sure uh we're kind of in a class
of our own of [ __ ] posting okay yeah
most people should post 10 minute videos
15 videos no no no no we do four hour
videos folks but it [ __ ] up a lot of
their processes so when you want to do
like a quick snip that might take 10
minutes on a 10 minute video on a four
minute video it takes like all night all
day with no monetization
and then when it finishes
the audio slipped this happened to us
once before the audio slipped like 20
seconds
Jimmy Lee is going to start claiming us
now he knows he can oh no
yeah so the audio slipped like 20
seconds
um due to that cut it didn't really like
process it correctly and so I'll show
you guys what it looks like
let's see
listen guys yeah it's horrible until
midnight on Wednesday it's unwatchable I
saw someone on the suburb I had a pretty
funny uh solution they had two windows
open so this is actually good for people
that want to watch it and play the audio
of one of them 20 seconds delayed could
that explain the increase in views
possibly does that count oh double up oh
we should do it every episode it could
be that and it could just be people
coming to check if it's fixed yet right
yeah it could also be this this uh
Shameless clickbait
no
no we delivered It's a combination of
all things yeah no we delivered on that
you'll have to watch the whole episode
to find out very end no skipping either
but um so anyway I there YouTube does
have a way of fixing it and I wrote to
them and uh they were very quick to
respond actually I got a new rep at
YouTube who's awesome love him so much
better hell yeah I don't want to talk
[ __ ] but
he's so much better
love him already
so he's getting it uh sorted where they
they do this thing where they can swap
out the old one
for a new one
which has the fixed audio but it's
taking it's been going now for like you
know 15 hours again because it's four
hours long but it should be fixed any
second here now guys so
if anyone's wondering what the f
happened that's what happened
but it should be fixed soon but you know
hey we're here the audio's synced now
right let's just enjoy it while we have
it what do we do about it
um
gosh
today's episode is sponsored by nobody
in particular that's great let's go baby
actually it is sponsored by somebody
Ayla Klein there's one day left
one day left folks
of our 50 off sale
ends tonight at midnight
so if you ever wanted to get some spicy
hot
Teddy fresh
at an incredible discount 50 off
Now's the Time
teddyfrish.com
go check it out see if there's something
you like 50 50 50. yeah check it out
uh Ian I just noticed you're wearing one
of our beautiful sweaters
you like that I love that one right I
mean it's nice yeah this is the first
time I've worn it and I really like it
nice thanks dude
probably could have worn it before I
mean how long has that been sitting here
I was waiting for it to get like really
hot outside yeah and I put it on
yeah LA's not the great place to wear
really anything but a shirt
sometimes you gotta you know give it all
for the fit it might be cold in here
though yeah yeah
some days it's too hot the AC in the
weather fight and the AC doesn't always
win yeah this building does not have
good insulation oh that's hot I could
literally see outside
there's some cracks in the room
[Laughter]
um
but yeah there's a lot of good stuff
still
teddyfresh.com 50 off all Super Troopers
listen up
head on over
yeah baby
yep there you go
I made a meme by the way you guys want
to see it you yeah for Teddy fresh
Instagram
I made all of these
oh well with Cam's help of course but I
you know
he did the Photoshop so what do you
think it's Noah dripped out end of the
world drip that's the that's the joke
obviously
but you know what if you're getting on
that Arc just because you're the last
person on Earth doesn't mean you still
don't need to look good
yes we do we wasn't the last
yeah him and his wife his daughter wives
that he repopulated the Earth with wait
were they were they his daughters well I
mean they were the only people who
survive a flood how did they repopulate
well his wife I thought his wife okay oh
his wife and his kids so where'd those
kids come from just saying you know
where all the product of Noah's incest I
didn't talk about that in my Torah
portion yeah
wait wait wait wait wait wait let me
Google that
did Noah did
Noah sleep with his daughters I mean
there's only one man dude you do the
math
here's a top post from quora
did Noah of the Bible sleep with his
daughters After the flood
according to the daughter he didn't have
and according to the story to have
daughters he did have three sons oh and
since they were all married he also had
three daughter-in-laws
the Bible does not mention anything
about him sleeping with them Dan how
dare you I was just reading between the
lines but it sounds like I need to brush
up on my Noah lore sex oh well here's
actually another top answer no
Noah's flood is fictional event
oh right yo what the [ __ ]
damn a myth invented by people who
didn't even know where rain comes from
that's a [ __ ] dunk damn
religion it's got absolutely correct
amen Checkmate atheists
well there it is folks although there'd
be some there'd be cousin insists then
at the very least if it's just right
boys and their wives then cousins be
[ __ ] yeah I guess that's true right
right there's no
other way to do it okay same with Adam
and Eve's kids too
oh man those kids are [ __ ] up dude
sexual desire of any sort well they're
they were just brother he was that was
his brother and sister even worse
because he was technically a clone of
Adam I mean she's just his rib right uh
yeah that's identical DNA
right
yeah I suppose so I mean gender swapped
gender swept yeah God was the original
um like anime weeaboo gender swapping
characters just like
take a little bit of this yeah they look
they make her look kind of like sexy and
all the depictions it was just Adam with
a wig
God
there you have it guys the Bible has got
some questionable things happening in
there the Bible I've never heard that
before is canceled
Checkmate atheist if I can't [ __ ] my
sister then explain Adam and Eve
oh God that's good oh no
but I made all three of these which is
your favorite the Homer the end is near
the house on fire dog
or the Noah I like The Simpsons one yeah
that one hit pretty hard too huh I
really got Chris in that uh that second
post oh yeah I got crazy dude Macy made
such a good
reels slash tick tock
let me see
oh is this just a copyrighted song is
that what's going on let's see
yeah to our fans and followers after our
50 off sale ends we will stop making
clothes uh indefinitely
and it was just you know
you got cursed it's funny I saw the
trunk I saw this on Tick Tock and I was
like yo what the hell
even got me good
well anyway uh now that we're all
learning where the product event says
Where Do We Go From Here well
uh Zach I saw on Twitter that you have
an ingrown toe that is crushing your
soul yeah it's uh it's like the
umpteenth time this year why does that
keep happening to you it's just genetics
it's like hereditary it's your dad he's
a descendant of Noah your mom yeah my
mom uh girl mom gets ingrowns well she
did until she got the surgery
um to get rid of it and uh what's that
surgery what do they remove so what they
do is they numb you up they cut the side
of your toenail and then they put an
acid on like a cotton swab like a long
stick and then they kill the root which
I need to have that done so they just
eliminate the nail
pretty much yeah and so there's no more
your mom doesn't have a toenail anymore
no she does she sells a toner they just
cut the side of the nail where the nail
gets ingrown dude that looks brutal so
it just this nail just grows into the
side of your toe it's the worst pain you
will ever experience all these whoa they
look like some of these pictures are
pretty gnarly and you know I watch does
it look like this
no it's not curved that bad that's
called like a Ram's Horn oh yeah do you
have it but um mine's not that bad it's
bad but it's um and my podiatrist I go
to is out of town this week of course so
I found another one I'm going tomorrow
and hopefully they you said it's the
most painful thing you've ever felt
absolutely it has like a sack of pus
that looks very painful so can we show
it
yeah
drum roll
do you want me to take my foot out
I want to smell feet let's show it I
mean uh let's let the world know what
and guys just a little obviously I guess
uh toe warning here it's the most Fair
toe warning look away
I'm personally interested I know a lot
of people are probably eating lunch
right now
how should I do this you just want me to
hold it up but I'm giving you guys all a
toe warning now we need a close-up Abe
get in there
and if you could describe the smell as
well maybe wait maybe here I'll use my
phone so we can zoom in on it yeah we'll
give guys I don't know why I'm
volunteering for this I really don't
want them guys if you don't want to see
the toe we'll give a we'll give a toe
warning
before we show it okay
but speak going back to the Bible people
say you know intelligent design people
who don't believe in evolution this
motherfucker's toe is growing into his
foot
there is no God
that's true there's no designer
Checkmate Fierce why would God create a
toe to go grow back into his own foot
toenail wait you guys should get a toe
warning
wait wait it's not on the screen is it
it was you got we gotta give a toe
warning Ian I said I told the good
people watching that we would give a toe
warning
sorry
all right guys this is your toe warning
I just want to point out this green
right here is just nail polish because I
thought that was part of the infection
but it's not you're talking about the
black outline the black I could take my
polish off there's some green right here
awful you see how red and inflamed it is
uh it doesn't look that bad but I do see
how inflamed it is can I see it from the
front I just want to see if we can see
the curvature of the
you don't really see the curvature
because it goes in earlier I think at
least I have this too you get that right
yeah right here is where you can see the
pus I had to lift my nail yesterday so
what do they do they cut the nail and
then they tweeze it out they go away
yeah and cut it out yeah your feet are
kind of gnarly dude there's a lot of
[ __ ] all over black socks oh that's okay
socks I wasn't going to say anything but
I was like ow you dig that's a that's a
tonger right there dude can you get the
light under it get the light on the side
of it so I can see or not under it but
like to the side of it
yeah yeah dude it [ __ ] hurts
bro I think all that sucks much is
probably
probably not health is that a new sock
yeah okay that makes sense
wow yeah all right the toe the toe
warning is lifted
Chad's saying why is it so dark dude
have you ever had a new sock on you like
yeah that happens thank you love no come
on it's a new sock I get it if it wasn't
then I'd really question what's
happening brand new uh brand new sock
there you have it but yeah the [ __ ] okay
toe warning is lifted everybody [ __ ] is
just off I can't I can barely walk
that's horrible man yeah I feel your
pain bro I could if you get me um pliers
or whatever in a tweezers I could try to
do it
for the show well they said they'll like
cauterize it right they cauterize it no
no no no
I guess that's one of the procedures I
saw a lot of people saying you need to
get it cauterized that's more invasive
um they like actually take a scalpel and
cut the skin around your toe right which
I don't think I need that done
but uh I just need to get the [ __ ]
nail out dude I saw someone say we
should see what sea man thinks oh oh
that's a yo you should show that clip to
see man maybe someone could just clip
that and then email him and we can get
comment from him it's pretty ingrown I
guess it's pretty I don't know bro it's
pretty gross I don't know I guess you
know new socks you know it leaves a
little residue but I like it no I'm not
kidding who's in who's in contact with
c-man I think it was Dan Dan was it me
okay again you're on that
should I just send him a picture without
any yeah or the video yo dude what's up
what do you think of this yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah give him a toe warning yeah
you know other things that prove God
doesn't exist uh a b almost choking on a
great on us dying on eating a piece of
steak
uh I did almost choke but I do believe
in God right so he saved me yeah God
saved you I guess maybe I should be more
specific that
you're almost dying on a piece of steak
he's clearly not out there no I'm just I
could argue the opposite okay what is it
I survived oh my God but why would he
make you I'm not I'm not trying to he's
testing he's testing his faith yeah I'm
not I'm not going down that road but I
was saying against
um
intelligent design the theory that
evolution is [ __ ] because God
perfectly uh engineered our bodies to
choke to death on [ __ ] steak
well I was more appreciative for life
after the fact
so that's something you were happy to be
alive happy to be alive yeah
yeah actually here's an ingrown toenail
that that's really nasty
that's uh Andrew Tate ladies and
gentlemen that [ __ ] definitely needs to
be cauterized yeah we need to do
something about that we're gonna have to
remove the toe buddy
related
what are we gonna do what are we gonna
do about it [ __ ] toe looks like man
we haven't talked to c-man since
November of 2020. that's what's up we
got to get female back on the phone I
guess it's good I don't know maybe I
don't know I don't know do you believe
in evolution maybe and and all that or
do you intelligent design guy
I think it's more a discussion for
another day wait you you you question
Evolution no oh
okay so it's a question it's not a
question for another no not a question
for another day oh okay
interesting
dude is there something we couldn't
unpack here or no no no no no no no okay
there it is folks I like the Twilight
movies well that explains
God doesn't exist bro Twilight movies
disprove his existence
hmm tobra Tate people say Toby okay over
tape
um welcome everybody
actually since we're on the um
the issue of Cobra Tate you guys have
been going crazy after I pointed out how
goofy this guy actually looks
specifically this Frame here like this
[ __ ]
is goofy as hell and so people really
been pointing out on the subreddit doing
some good job this Dude Looks Like
Voldemort living on the back of another
man's Dome
the man looks like he's got another face
on the back of his head in it
look at this that's Cobra Tate that is
cobra that's what he looks like
that's what I was talking about when I
said like birth defect tape
with peace and love and I say that you
know with all the love in the world for
all of our birth defected uh
people out there
what counts as a birth defect do I have
a birth defect like Tourette's
uh yeah well yeah I guess it's genetic
so Earth defect or is it like I think if
you were born with it
so I have a birth defect
I think life is a birth defect
damn dude thanks bro from Death to life
here is uh he he also looks like the
dude who got his head shrunk and
Beetlejuice for sure
oh I love that one I think this is the
best way to combat uh cobrote is to real
reveal what a beta he is
uh here is Cobra Tate
as dancing
whatever his name is
does he have a name
yeah he does it's like Wallace or
something it's horse oh yeah horse
oh yeah this
um this of course he was also actually
made two cameos in Harry Potter
this is the troll from Harry Potter very
similar looking vibes
yep
the bubble uh Radiohead the bends I
haven't seen that though one's my phone
that is my favorite wait what's that are
you not familiar I don't know what the
album cover
[Laughter]
pretty accurate man
oh [ __ ]
[Laughter]
yeah dude the bubbles right it's like
it's pretty close the bubble uh
um Cobra taint oh and the Benz gives you
bubbles it all ties together
okay yeah here we go there's some really
good cartoonists here love this I mean
that's right this is what you look like
Cobra what's your girl it's your girl
I just want you to know this is what you
look like
it's before you get all tough and Alpha
and also like this part two
yeah and also you're the you came you're
the alien
uh that comes out of the tummy of uh
damn there's more earthworm
a snake's on a plane
uh Joe Rogan's nipples of course that's
my favorite
the back of Voldemort's Dome we thought
we saw that one looks great
he's also I mean this is a Vibe yeah
make an airless Beaver something naked
mole rat yeah naked mole rat getting
that so there you go you guys feel free
to use any of these in his comments
we need to demasculate him it's all he
has
it's your girl this girl ninja girl
love that for him
mm-hmm
also something we need to discuss here
this meme on the subreddit went Mega
viral
quote unquote of course three thousand
points
people really think they're funny
Ethan talked about Muslim religion oh
dear
Ethan talking about Christianity you
[ __ ] donkey
yeah I guess it's funny but I was just
surprised how many people
I guess notice that Trend as well
I think
if I can give my theory on this
I think in this country
the norm is for people to [ __ ] on on
Muslims and to not say anything about
Christianity
I it's not like I don't I'm not like a
Muslim simp though I've said plenty of
[ __ ] I talk about Isis I talked about
how like all the gulf countries are like
basically slave states and anyone that
goes to Dubai is kind of like supporting
a [ __ ] slave state
and Qatar too
um which we're going to talk about here
but I don't know I mean you know I'm I'm
not down with with fundamentalists of
any religion they're all horrible one
thing I do talk about a lot is how a lot
of the fun the Christians in this
country running the government are
starting to look more and more like Isis
every day
um
also Muslims are not turning this
country into a fascist State it's not a
hostile takeover by Muslim fascists in
my backyard
on the other hand you have Theocratic
fascist freaks
um in our Congress on a Supreme Court
and then all walks of life so yes
I don't have much of a tolerance for for
the extremists but you know
I think a lot most
yeah I don't know
well I appreciate it yeah uh yeah no
post 911 definitely islamophobia has
gone up significantly uh growing up post
911 uh yeah and I I don't even look uh
Middle Eastern right you know and so and
I I still got it when I started out on
YouTube I'd even you know I didn't
reveal my name was Abdullah I hid my
name I went by an American name
um but you're American
Starkiller no I went by Abel actually
okay Abel yeah weekend for that that's a
that's a Biblical name in it yeah but
it's not a Muslim name oh it's a
Christian name yeah you try to go
Incognito yeah you know when I started
out in Israel I did that too I hid
really all the stars of David's and [ __ ]
and like we had a backpack with the star
David on it that that I we covered we
put a patch over it yeah
it's funny yeah I don't think I mean
I don't think Christians are being
persecuted the same way in this country
man hell no yeah [ __ ] show me your
Christian tears [ __ ] Jesus died for you
just [ __ ] enjoy the ride
I think um if I can offer my two cents I
think uh
that sentiment may also come from the
fact that when you are when we're
talking about uh Muslims you make clear
the distinction like that you're talking
about like Isis or or you know sort of
Hardcore fundamentalists whereas with
Christianity uh you know when you get
very heated about that
um you don't really
you like say things like [ __ ] these
Christians or whatever and you know uh
what you just said had a lot more Nuance
you're talking about fundamentalists of
any kind of which there are plenty in
this country
um but of course there are plenty of
Christians in this country and
everywhere that are just normal good
people so maybe making that distinction
a little bit more clear that you're
talking about like psychotic
you know Evangelical I guess I just
assumed that's more obvious in the
context of where we are and who we are
right it is it is to people that know
you well but but
um I guess it's a funny meme oh dear oh
dear gorgeous that I mean I like
but uh
listen we love our Christian fans don't
we folks unless you [ __ ] kids then we
don't love you but the thing is the
thing about Christianity oh that I feel
like I can I can criticize it broadly
I'm Justified is because the insta
there's like an institution the church a
pope
okay but throughout the country in the
world that shuffle these Catholics right
yeah that's the thing is most people are
Catholic no well not in this country uh
worldwide I believe Catholicism is the
biggest Christian denomination but yeah
I think that you're just I mean I
remember on this show I think you
understand this now but it was like two
or three years ago
you I had to explain to you that there
is a difference between Catholics and
other Christians like I think you're
just kind of ignorant about Christianity
come on
well yeah and like the different
denominations and what the differences
between them are and everything and so
I don't know yeah you're right I don't I
don't make those things being extremists
and um
and normal normal ass Christians there's
just so much extremism in this [ __ ]
country it's hard to make a distinction
I'll be honest man I was raised Catholic
and there was a stark difference going
to my Catholic Church versus going to
like my friends Baptist Church or
Protestant church it was like so the
Baptist or the dub dub Christians
which one do we say bye-bye to we don't
like the KKK Christians we don't like
well what do you mean Sam
what do you mean which one was like
there was one that was more extreme or
like what was the difference
um I guess it was just um and also like
it was Southern Baptist so it was just a
very different
way I guess of interpreting the Bible
and I found personally that the Baptist
Church was a lot more extreme
like I remember sermons like they would
straight up tell you like if you have
pre-marital sex you're going to hell
like I never really like that Southern
Southern Baptists are pretty intense yes
I specifically I went to a youth group
with one of my friends and the pastor
bought a Subway sandwich and he took a
bite out of it chewed it up and spit it
on the floor and he said that's like
that's your Purity that's what you do to
God if you have sex before marriage just
while he's eating a sandwich no he like
bought the sandwich I think to do this
like if you get a foot long or a six
inch I think it was a foot long just for
the gag you didn't even get the six inch
Dam yeah that's an ex he put down some
extra cash on that
but so just to give an example of why I
say there's some nuance and some
complexity to it you you know rightfully
criticize the Catholic church for all
their sexual abuse scandals and
everything but you were just talking
about people uh like intelligent design
and people don't believe in evolution
Catholics uh generally believe in
evolution they're not nearly as
anti-science as a lot of other Christian
denominations so
um I didn't accuse anyone of being no
but I'm just I'm giving you an example
of like design right but you you were
like which ones are the good ones which
one of them bad ones come on I'm kidding
I I know you're kidding but I'm just
explaining here's the here's a I just
people just got voted in
the pope of drip send me uh
hope Ethan the Divine boy
dude why the pope so drip the [ __ ] out
by the way no way they're all about the
Aesthetics they they I have the popes
bro I did on a shirt
yeah no that's that's the holy bro
that's Hawaiian right
that is not Hawaiian all right and my
wife made that shirt
my uh my family grew up Uber Catholic
and uh we left the church like
immediately after the whole sex scandal
came out
right he's from Massachusetts that's
where that all started that's really
interesting so you all actually got this
communicated yourself after that yeah
and I I was so [ __ ] happy because
church was always just boring as [ __ ] I
didn't have any like issue with like the
sermons or anything I just was always
[ __ ] bored
well that's super interesting I I I'm
happy to know that some people at least
uh but you can have faith outside the
church anyway to all my Christian
Brothers who I have painted with a broad
brush I say to you
that uh
I say to you now in all humility
I Fall to my needs
and say
suck my tiny Jewish dick here we go
Jesus died for your ass what the [ __ ] do
you care about what I say you're going
to heaven anyway even if you do [ __ ]
kids
no I'm just kidding I I apologize for
for painting a brown Bush on that one
there
I'll try to be more specific about
Christian extremists
versus uh
Christian good boys
shut up Mecca by the way shout out the
love just said in Sweden the main
Protestant Church the Lutheran Church
our uh pro-choice generally and I think
that's the case here too lutherans are
fairly liberal uh Christian denomination
we love that I don't believe lutherans
are uh yeah letharians are super cool I
don't [ __ ] with religion but
Libertarians uh they seem pretty oh
lutherans maybe maybe we're talking
about different things or maybe it's
just pronounced no I don't know is there
sex of like Muslim or Islam and
Christianity where like I'm a reformed
Jew like we're basically atheists
yeah remember what I'm saying right yeah
do you have like Christians and Muslims
who are basically like we [ __ ] with the
religion in a cultural way but we don't
we don't really mean Hassan
examples I don't think in Islam there is
something as as uh Progressive as Reform
Judaism but certainly there are
Christian denominations that are very
Progressive the the church that I've
talked about that I went to Growing Up
started as a Christian Church I I think
you could probably say it's not even
Christian at this point with the like
you said I mean it there there are
agnostics that go to that church now and
everything
um so yeah you know there's there's a
[ __ ] ton of denominations and they all
have their own idiosyncrasies you know
I've known Christian people in my life
who are like super
um
Progressive and sweet and like yeah
people who have left churches because
they were had homophobic Vibes and and
uh
I think this is a good comment though
fundamental Christians are ruining the
United States fundamental Muslims are
ruining turkey Ethan lives in the United
States
and even more specifically yeah
and Jews excuse me Jordan Jews
but
listen I'm I'm pretty much and I
I'm not uh I don't love religion just
you know what I'm saying I think that's
not a secret about me but I you know I'm
not I'm not gonna hate on people's Faith
either you know it works for some people
yeah
and that's fine yeah religion's
definitely led to more deaths than
anything else in history oh yeah
you know when when religion starts
making you hate gay people and kind of
that [ __ ] then then you know
your brain on Jesus
this is your brain on Jesus crack an egg
over a [ __ ] hot skillet
if we are not Brothers in faith we are
brothers in humanity
that's a good one
is that a is that a profit uh uh well I
think so shut up the prophet Muhammad
can I say his name or is that sacrilege
you can say yeah okay I just can't draw
him right yeah we're gonna have
depictions yeah
that's like some of his earliest videos
drawing the prophet and like
talking [ __ ] about it Steve Crowder oh
yeah I'm not doesn't surprise me at all
lovely wait how do you know what what he
looks like if you could there's no
depictions there's no depictions what's
the reason for that
I I'm not sure honestly
a lot of stuff
isn't it about like Idol tree like yeah
you're not he's not the idol he's the
guy yeah right but you know yeah no
Dan's right and a lot of stuff in Islam
like
you're not it's not supposed to be like
manipulated the way like they
whitewashed like Jesus in a way you know
he's just like straight Aryan yeah yeah
right
Elena is that what uh is that why we
don't draw Muhammad
yeah I think that's the reason we keep
it we keep the idea of him pure yeah
before he gets blue eyes and white skin
right okay pictures as well as statues
are thought to encourage the worship of
Idols so yeah it's it's about idle tree
so those guys are doing a good job on
the Ten Commandments better than the
Christians even
um okay Muslims are the real Christians
shut the [ __ ] out dude and therefore I
hate them
saying I just found a loophole I hate
Chris Muslims as much as Christians
we'll get you yeah you know what I I'm a
reformed Jew that means that we were
formed God straight the [ __ ] out of our
religion
that's what that means
I love reformed Judaism it's awesome
it's basically calm down when's the last
time you've been to synagogue
do they still call it in synagogue in
reform or is it just Temple
they call it Temple actually Temple
right right yeah but uh the last time I
was in a synagogue or Temple was
probably
well I recently walked through one at uh
Theodore's school because he goes to a
Jewish preschool right
uh the accounts you were in there I
walked through it yeah but that was the
first time probably in decades
to be honest wow
yeah and there you have it folks
it's a little uh tour of all the great
religions of the world
we love that
we're gonna be breaking down Buddhism
next week Hinduism and Jedi and of
course yes in the force yeah so tune in
actually we do have a great show Jimmy
Lee is calling in at two because he
dropped a very offensive joke that I
need to confront him on hold it after
that we've got a fun segment Plan called
smell my fungur in order of Dan's
birthday
which is uh tomorrow my birthday is
tomorrow but let's not get ahead of
ourselves my birthday is unimportant
today because there is an actual
birthday today
Jesus oh oh Jesus and it kind of looks
like Jesus a little bit cut the long
hair that's Jesus wait oh it's Cameron's
birthday today it's today it sure is
happy birthday cam Kevin Cameron happy
birthday how come it's not on my
calendar
I have Cameron
oh man happy birthday captain can you
add that to my calendar Lena
yeah I got it happy birthday cam happy
birthday Cameron we got you a present
it'll be here on Friday okay sweet I'll
stand by for that can I real quick uh
give a thank you to Abe and Lena for
getting me these Crocs
oh you got birthday cards yeah that's
nice I die
sweet man Kansas good people Kim
[Applause]
you stuck your own dick Camp uh I'll try
another time yeah let me know because
those pretty flexible I'm just saying
I'll report back yeah let me know let us
all know Cameron is doing a fantastic
job I think he's a star yes but we love
Cameron Cameron's been with us uh just
over a year yeah
he has graced us
and thrilled us with his his presence
his Incredible video uh artistic skills
and uh he's been an absolute asset to
the team we celebrate you Cameron and we
love you very much it's also um Billy
mays's birthday today so I'll Forever
Living his shadow
Billy Mays the awkward wrestling guy
yeah resting peace to a King rest though
it's also young Lin's birthday today
okay young lean's birthday I love young
Lee loves Idol yes and Jesus is it is
not Jesus's birthday I don't know where
you're getting that from
wait does does that does the prophet
have a birthday Muhammad uh yeah I'm
sure he's his birthday I don't think we
celebrate it like that by the way that
was Imam Ali who said that quote I said
um
I know but Jesus is a prophet
to us he's more than a prophet a b I'm
just too
uh that's sacrilege he's God himself
malid is Muhammad's birthday what's the
date
uh well this year it's on October 7th
they're they're the calendar is like the
Jewish calendar it changes itself a
little bit over here
Jesus you guys don't celebrate his
birthday what the hell dude
well it looks like they do so not to
call you out you're getting called out
right now maybe Lena you celebrate Mommy
it's not like a big one though not me
personally but I was gonna say Abita it
was wrong on that because I have family
who will like not like a huge
celebration but they'll visit relatives
and like bring something with them like
a tray of sweets or something okay there
you go it seems like something you
should want to celebrate the Miller was
born Loki affair
yeah the bigger I don't know we have a
shooter coming out which is like uh Lena
you want to explain that
somehow this is a bigger deal in our
eyes
a shooter a shooter
a shooter yeah I don't like to talk too
much religion but it's just like she's
afraid she's gonna get [ __ ] oh you don't
yeah yeah I got you but you want Dan to
look it up and describe it
that's okay I can just briefly say it's
like the bomb the murder of the
prophet's family so um Muslims just
observed that time period
okay shut the [ __ ] out yeah
for 10 days you're like not supposed to
do anything fun and you're supposed to
mourn and I agree bro why they always
got to go down with it well yeah and my
my dad's family like my dad's sisters
want to want to do 40 days
oh my God yeah so
shout out to Mary who gave 400 and said
a modest tithing
back again family I cleaned up and
revamped the site wait this is the
hairline one Carolina hierarchy Airline
hierarchy thank you for the modest
tithing someone check the website see if
we can look at it I'm growing my hair
people
but yeah so Jimmy's calling in yeah it's
just about ready and then we're gonna
play smell my finger
and then also we have another segment of
keemstar beef jerky taste test
so we have basically a whole episode of
fun wonderful segments playing here
today for everyone's enjoyment wow yes
off the rails baby we are certainly off
the rails now Jimmy's probably almost
ready to go right yeah did you I sent
him the link okay okay so let's get it
this set up a little bit because Jimmy
posted this
now I'm just going to be warning it's a
little offensive to some people some of
our smaller statured Legends
is that the preferred nomenclature
little people
smaller statured Legends
stls
uh here's Jimmy's joke
I hate [ __ ] midgets man and that's a
lot to put out there just saying and in
the role of a life it's a hell of a way
to open up a video it's just the start
yeah that started
I hate [ __ ] midgets man I don't want
anybody sniffing around my fly unless
they're serious
so he says
what
I guess there's because they're at dick
level and he says hey if you're gonna be
down there you better suck it you know
what I'm saying unless they're oh okay
seriously like they opened to fellatio
him
I had to unpack something tells me we
didn't get through to him so last
episode he messaged that before he
posted it to me in cam
and I was shocked by it and then I go
and see that he [ __ ] posted it to
Instagram
oh he sent it to you first he sent it
first first did you tell him this the
shit's this is not it well I didn't get
a chance to uh I mean we were doing the
show when he sent it
I see so have you guys seen what's going
on in his Instagram by the way it's so
out of control he's just been fo
photoshopping himself
he he just texted to me
five minutes ago he just I think he just
sends it to me and then posts it
can I come clean about something here he
is he no you're not making these firm
cam are you not not these but I made a
few oh you've owned a SpongeBob which
ones did you make uh he posts so much I
don't I made a SpongeBob one that's the
last one I made for him like check this
out audio audio audio
the great words the great words he also
keeps implying that
he and Diana Ross is your parents yeah
yeah that's a classic like he wants that
point across well he's about to meet my
dad and and have a day with him so
yeah it's gonna when and that's coming
up like next week right next next week
guys this is going to be explosive my
dad and Jimmy Lee together maybe they
should go to a ball game and just start
stabbing beach balls we got to get them
doing all kinds of stuff together
uh this is my favorite Jimmy Lee post
histrionic histrionic personality
disorder hey
dot dot dot history histrionic
personality disorder
if you don't like me you can
foreign
love that he's just owning it though you
know what this is very histrionic
personality disorder of him he uh I
think posts at least like every hour in
the day
yeah this is a weird one he keeps
posting [ __ ] about that he's my real dad
and I just don't quite get
where you're going with this one here
Jimmy well the the whole
um thing with him being your dad and
Diana Ross being your mother it goes
back to the roast we did for you Ethan
okay where we had to censor uh his um oh
my God that's right so I think that's
where it's it's coming from what was the
joke do you remember he made a very
awful uh foreign
you being the product of him and a black
woman
um having intercourse yes I'm half black
well it was his phrasing of it he did
not use yeah the best language he is a
racial slur no well not the racial slur
that you're probably thinking right
right like Velveteen Rabbit eyes cut
type deep yes it's some deep racism yeah
here's another one I got histrionic
personality disorder hey work with me
Bingo his roast was the origin of
tomatoes in the chat it's true oh that's
good that's how it all started well okay
Jimmy is uh
late I said join
yeah I'm keeping an eye on it he has
nothing yet apparently oh this is the
one that cam made for oh here I got it
so Cameron you've been sending him these
this is probably yeah this one's good
sometimes yeah I mean Jimmy Lee the
undersea Outlaw we love that
hey work with me people it's clean
should you should be paying you for that
work
yeah I agree he wrote he drives a
Rolls-Royce man you gotta shake him down
Kim
when he comes back I'll shake him down
yeah he owes you money we'll have to hit
him up
[Music]
so well it while we wait I've got some
stuff at the top of the show I want to
watch here's James Charles man
again
I talk about James Charles
uh and it's just it's incredible to me
he still has quite a lot of fans like if
you go to tick tock we looked at his
YouTube channel which is pretty much a
graveyard
but his Tick Tock is still popping buddy
like
um I mean five days 700 000 views again
not bad but for him it's like a travesty
but if you go to tick tock
he's popping off still man and this next
video comes from tick tock
three million three million
uh
this one has 27 million
listen there's nothing wrong with the
tuck but this just makes me uncomfy
do you know what I mean does this make
you uncomfy
all right it's not very hello
yeah right also why is he sniffing his
finger where's that sniffer that finger
bin you freak watch she sniff his finger
bro it's part of The Tick Tock dance the
sound
they say like turn up their nose or
something like that yo he's sniffing his
finger though bunker
fungus
he must be in physical pain if I mean
it's like it hurts yeah apparently maybe
there's a way
no apparently he said somewhere that he
does tape it back right
yeah it's what uh drag queens do it's
called tucking yes they tuck it yes if
you do it well it won't hurt I don't
know never tried it I mean you probably
get used to it I just hit my balls
but he where'd that finger was dude
sniffing it like that
but ah yeah I just uh I don't know I
hate him so much
but anyway here's the tick tock I wanted
to watch with you guys
um
he's posting his L's now
I have so much entertainment from
watching people try so hard to get the
top comment on my videos by saying dumb
[ __ ] like this
glue does this even mean he thought he
did something
babe what what tea what do you think
that I think I did
like do you envision me like heading
posts on this video and sitting there
being like Oh
she really likes here we go this is the
video you guys this is it he's actually
so bothered by the comments
that's what it's telling me
right
yeah when I was watching this earlier it
just kept going like it's it's long
enough that you know like this really
mattered
crying through the laughter
yeah really sad
I just
I just need 30 seconds to film hit post
haven't thought about it since
it's not that deep
yeah but you know why people don't like
you right
because you're a predator and I was
called out and labeled as a predator so
I'm just saying like
you know why people don't like it I mean
it's easy to call out these little these
like
10 follower accounts but at the end of
the day
let's talk about the issue at hand here
I'm taking this very very seriously
what do you think you did with this
comment
do you think this is going to be your
moment
yeah I thought it was gonna kill my role
2 000 likes from bullying James Charles
time to quit the job move to LA become a
star
yeah
God I love this app anyway what's your
Snapchat
um what's what's crazy to me is you if
you go to this comment section it's all
30 000 likes no because this is actually
funny why are you actually funny
get 2 000 likes and move to LA dying of
laughter
it's not funny it's embarrassing dude
so what's happening here
it's crazy bro
people say parents need to be aware of
what their kids are watching parents
need to be aware their kids are watching
James Charles man
because he's coming for your kids
hey
stop laughing it's not funny exactly
uh James weiner is in the lobby of the
call just just so you know okay let's
bring him on so there you have it though
on the James Charles ladies and
gentlemen every time he tucks he gets a
lot of views this one has 20 million
three and I figured I would finally it
says where'd it go
so we just got back
downstairs my friends for my 23rd
birthday it was an amazing time we were
by the pool every single day and of
course when you're swimming
why is he standing like that probably
show off the BBL oh who stands like that
he's like
I don't know how to show it but he's
standing one foot in front of the other
dude
trying to act like that's just how he
stands
what are you doing a sobriety test
standing fraud
standing fraud that's what he's serving
by the way nothing wrong with the talk
you know what I'm saying it's just James
Charles's a predator and that's why
uh hi I'm dick Tipp but you know talk it
back man be proud and Tuck that [ __ ]
back bro
bathing suit no I wore this one and
several other like this and they caused
quite a ruckus on social media swimmer
has always been a really weird clothing
category because I've never been able to
find anything that I was comfortable and
confident in of course I have my boys
bathing suit shorts but I don't feel
like these were very flattering and I
didn't like having my nipples out but I
also would never wear a bikini because I
don't have you know boobs to fill the
top this picture of Kim at the beach
changed everything for me because it was
the first time that I saw a bathing suit
and thought to myself oh my God I would
wear that so I reset my friend Marco
Marco who's an incredible designer and
he made me custom bathing suits and
black neon green blue gray and the one
piece ombre and I know it's a little bit
different but this is the first time
that I've ever had swimwear that I feel
comfortable and confident in and finally
to answer your question yes it's still
there it's just talked okay so he stuck
to you back now is there special tuck
tape
can you do some research on that for me
somebody I've heard drop Queens talk
about it like a lot of drag queens are
just super hardcore and they use like
mechanical tape even or like people to
get it done they use
um
like wig glue for their eyelashes some
people wow yeah okay you got to get it
done yeah at all costs
let's ask Jimmy about it no
no no okay let's bring him on let's not
just bring them on and see where this
goes okay uh I will let him in
right now stand by
um but is there special tape can you
look that up for me please baby yeah
apparently you can use medical tape
okay normal medical type so but what's
the process of tucking it do you tuck it
to your back or your thighs or
if you tuck it there's different
processes the back the way that people
speak it's it sounds upward you do it up
and back that's what that's what I think
but I can look up a process and let you
know yeah if you and maybe wikiHow as a
step by step
all right give me talk to me bye guys
Jimmy Lee the Jersey outlaw
we're here baby boy how are you where
are you right now
we're at the famous August Diner in
Marlton and before we go any further
happy birthday to cam come on guys
that's nice
that's pretty nice is that Ringo
he actually picked up on a sofa field
for the first time in his life
hey uh Jimmy is that Ringo Star next to
you
no I have to confess that Osama Bin
Laden anything yeah is not dead
who is this can I get a piece of love
get a piece of love Joe there he is
Harry Mandel he does that look or he'll
do to Kenny Rogers we'll put that back
on let me talk to him let me talk to
your friend give him the phone that's
Walter White that's it
how you doing today what are you doing
what are you doing with Jimmy uh isn't
it embarrassing
been friends for uh 20 years now wow
he's a good guy very very thoughtful
kind he's a photographer he's an actor
he's a paid actor get him out of here
it's Jimmy's photographer in New York
actually it's my photographer this guy's
a paid extra no I have he's paying him
you know who Ripley
Ripley I I don't know are you guys too
young Jack do you remember Ripley yeah I
don't know I know what Ripley's Believe
It or Not is yeah
we have the world's tallest man here
today Jolly Roger eight foot six there
he is hey Jolly Roger stand up
stature
eight foot six Zach he doesn't want to
okay great now Jimmy I have wanted I
need to confront you on something okay
okay now you put up a um
a video on Instagram that was just a tad
offensive
which one was that yeah you don't have
any idea which one I'm referring to I
know which one it was which one
I don't like midgets Ethan oh my God
I can't do it I'm sorry don't get mad I
just never liked the crowded elevator
this thing never went well with me with
midgets yeah that's a hard that's a
tough one to put out there dude but
first of all that the word the word
midgets is very offensive okay we don't
use that word anymore we got to get that
out I have to confess that AB asked me
to do it
Maybe
[Music]
Muslim joke
wait hey B are you there yeah he's there
he's just stunned I'm stunned yes
yeah but so so all right here let me
play the video uh
for for your reference here he says
yes man I don't want anybody
unless they're Series so so what's the
joke basically
I thought it was a pretty good joke
Jolly Roger liked it pretty funny okay
all right Jolly Roger
now now the joke is that little people
would be at dick height and you're
saying hey if you're going to be around
my dick you better suck it huh
it's a chick
if it's a chick so you don't you're not
down with
so you so you're okay with little people
who are men
but you don't like Little Women
no I said not guys chicks right
you got it it's just an old style joke
that's really what it was
hey Jimmy do you have any jokes about
abortion oh boy
no wow
wow
hey Jimmy what's your thoughts on the uh
oh did we lose yeah I can still hear you
what's your thoughts on the abortion uh
bans going on around the country
foreign
Jolly Roger it's the worst thing that
could happen man it's a right-wing
conspiracy oh what's up Roger
he's right
put that man up for Jolly Roger for
president
we may have to because he's running for
congress actually
[Laughter]
New Jersey
yeah you have a real big fan Reagan from
Israel and she just texted me she went
to the Wailing Wall and asked two Arabs
to leave and they did
[Music]
yeah but that's also their land I
thought it was a good one why why is
that okay Dan didn't like it Jimmy Jimmy
what I loved it what's this personally a
surprise you keep telling me about
Jimmy said he has a surprise okay all
morning let's see a pictures act that I
sent you
the one you posted on Instagram
yes and I think it's time Ethan needs to
know now that he's older who his real
parents are here we go and I think we
need to fess up now
and Ethan we put the picture up on the
weekend me and the kunatana Diana Ross
are your real name
and we need to fess up that we are your
real parents and Ethan needs to own that
did you pause that
pause that
well you're about to meet my real dad
you can tell him that joke in person
no that's we had a happy with that
because Diana was on tour with the
Supremes and we didn't have time to
bring you up because I was managing her
so Gary is the adopted father he didn't
want to say anything to get upset
so we gave you up right before you were
Bar Mitzvah okay so that's interesting
to know did you call Diana Ross um
Hakuna Matata yes
now do you want to unpack that for me
well I think it would be best if Zach
unpacks that if his Zack doesn't mind be
good Zach used to date her when he was
very young okay
so let's not let that out of the bag
Ethan I'm gonna I'm gonna message you
the word he meant to say do not repeat
it
send it to me Jimmy you're I feel like
we had an intervention and you've just
completely regressed
oh my God they knew how aggressed he was
it would be oh boy oh boy
oh [ __ ] that was his original wording
that and that's what we had to blur in
the roast
damn funny we just talked about it I
mean I feel like he it's super racist
but like you could show it
hold on Ethan we got we got H3 fans
coming from August Diner wish cam a
happy birthday hey happy birthday
what's up everybody make sure hey guys
do me a favor hey guys no spitting in
Jimmy's food all right every time you
get the shrimp Ethan you come home with
the crab every time
foreign
that's Anna Banana and this is big bad
Dom who eats the profit where are you
Tom here he is Italian Stallion Rocky
Balboa all right all right the Big Bang
forget about it
forget about it yeah Jimmy I don't know
man I I you know you really you got to
make a stronger effort here because
you're regressing and and you know we
made a lot of uh progress at redeeming
your your kind of racist Tendencies but
you're really slipping back into old
habits
so I have to come do my set next week my
clean set where I don't get buzzed too
much right
oh you're gonna get buzzed
an AV and I have to shake cans and we
got to pretend the Jewish Egyptian
things under the water forget about that
and just let that go
and uh by the way I hope you find a
place to park your camel
yeah we've heard that one well he didn't
laugh the first 12th time so I wanted
[Applause]
yeah and by the way AB you look good you
got your fer gun my sweatshirt your hats
are going to invite you for looking too
good
hey Jimmy
um
um Ethan want to do some lines do you
know the uh do you know the chef
a comedy show
no I don't think you meant Oh I thought
you meant blow do you know who the head
chef there is are you guys Buddies
oh God please yeah this is my regular
spot this is the world famous August
Diner in Cherry Hill yeah who's the head
chef back there
the head chef is Dominic who eats the
prophets that's why when you order they
don't bring too much food out because he
pretty much eats after your meal before
they bring it out and when they bring it
out generally if you order something hot
it's cold if you order something cold
and hot it's a whole [ __ ] up Dieter
but you know what they're nice people
yeah I wonder if maybe the chef would
like to say hi to you or something maybe
she'd like to meet you we may be saying
bye after that no I'm trying to get I'm
trying he doesn't want to go
what's that Jimmy I think it's actually
you being kosher this would be a great
place for you
I'm not Kosher though
all right Jimmy listen
we look forward
we I by the way I just want to say I
appreciate you embracing the histrionic
personality disorder that's become a
really funny going on joke did you like
the um post with where I said it I love
it isn't it no it's great it's like I've
got histrionic personality disorder work
with me
you liked it I love it I had to accept
it my son told me you know when I was
out there when I saw you for the podcast
you know he he mentioned it and uh we
had it we had to own up to it hey you
know what'd be funny
foreign
I don't want to have to say it Jimmy but
uh you're back in a restaurant we had a
lot of fun last time Jimmy you know what
to do man
you know what to do let's go
come on let's go oh here we go oh boy
you asked for attack I can't do it no we
didn't ask for it we didn't say anything
puppy
that's Peppy happy they want to know if
you have your papers
Jimmy stop no no no stop stop stop stop
stop stop stop you can't do that
come say hello
all right everybody say hello to Ethan
hey Jimmy just explain it Jimmy just
explain that you have histrionic
personality disorders they just got out
Zach the Melendez Brothers
we got to close the stream this is Dylan
Dylan say hi to Ethan
Jimmy
Jimmy
is that machine gun Rocky or Kelly which
came a happy birthday happy birthday
tell Cam to go on a vacation because I
can't go on a vacation yeah
he's not listening Jimmy can you ask him
if they have a large cane anywhere
Jimmy the cocaine can you hear me
he's purposely ignoring you he's gone
all right Dan where'd you go we need to
cut this [ __ ] out you couldn't he had to
go get together why would he leave at
this point we need him now dad you don't
need to make it you're the leading your
post dude during war bro
I need you to cut it off he's in the
kitchen asking where's their papers
wait wait wait wait wait wait okay Jim
you got to apologize for that joke of
the papers I just did apologize to the
chefs and just explain to them that you
have histrionic personality disorder so
they know yeah I told them that I was
told to do it by Zach the king Jew okay
they accepted it sorry sorry everybody
Jack is the king goo we'll see you next
week with my dad okay
oh now you're mad don't be mad no we're
not mad just dance
yeah we're not mad just just I thought
we worked on this Jimmy you we had you
in here you had a new set like I thought
this was going to be the new Jimmy Lee
any technical question about Jimmy Lee
I've known him since 1980. okay
interesting so he just went back in the
kitchen and asked the chefs if they have
their paperwork what do you think about
that
it's a classic yeah you know he's gonna
say that yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
all right he has certain things you
can't help but say yeah because I'm the
best man I'm this I was the best man at
Jimmy's wedding so wow so you have a
high time you know the real stars his
wife is still with him yeah I know yeah
you know what would make me feel better
Jimmy
yes just go back to the chefs and just
apologize for the papers joke
do it all right come on Raj you gotta go
I got the print security I just yeah
just tell them you know you're sorry
and uh you know
we got to find him where's Pepe yeah
did you guys see that one Chef was oh my
God no it's it's not the guy the guy we
saw he's not here let's go back in the
kitchen
well no you can't eat then go all the
way back because they they get mad you
can't go back
yeah somebody wants to say hello from um
Afghanistan
Jimmy you won't apologize you go in
there and say the offensive thing but
you won't I can't find the guy oh come
on we were only kids around with you
come here that's the guy hold on we're
only joking with you we're on a podcast
we were only no we were only teaching
this yeah Augustine there he is what's
your name [ __ ] Miguel we won't be
joking yeah yeah we're only teasing
we're just joking no you didn't say it
no no that's not an apology Jimmy hold
I'm sorry we're just joking around no he
knows he's cool all right ever since
it's bad it's American war everybody
it's all done oh God oh my God
surrendered and it's all over it's stuck
yeah you can just hang up then deal with
that later
Jesus Christ oh my God Jimmy Lee
everybody
horrible
I thought he was reformed yeah he's
completely lost his way man he's
relapsed he is totally relapsed he's
back on the wagon yeah comedically he
has relapsed God that was brutal man I
think he's ready for our big Jimmy
episode next week
what happened Jimmy he got so he got a
big head he missed her Showtime now it's
because he's on the Instagram he's on
Cameo now he's on Cameo he's on
Instagram he got a couple of fans he
picked up on Social Security with his
buddies too you know what I mean they
might not be a good influence Jimmy just
sent me a question mark
I'm cutting off the photoshops for now
okay we got damage control on that that
was nice that they sang you happy
birthday though cam yeah well thank you
that was kind of touching wasn't it yeah
the photoshops are still on pause though
but thank you for the birthday wishes
yeah man that was rough dude I didn't
expect them to go straight with the show
me the papers and then I thought I've
made a terrible mistake
uh
well we never asked him to do that and
go back I honestly didn't expect that
one
I should have though
there's a doozy
well let's move on well this is off the
wall so nobody can be mad our
Spanish-speaking audience is saying
adios adios adios
that's [ __ ] good in the words of
Jimmy that's actually pretty funny
you can use that one Jimmy audio uh
someone said Kirsten said racism is not
funny please stop giving him a platform
if he does have history on a personality
or store this is only hurting him and
enabling well
uh you're right we we work we thought we
could reform him
and he's he's
relapsed you know what I mean uh
but uh we're trying to teach we're
trying to make him a better man you know
trying to teach him
he was doing so great too he was he he
really was making progress he was doing
but then this is just you know but you
know what's going to be interesting
because next week he's going to meet
with my dad and my dad is very PC he's
very like he doesn't tolerate racist
jokes and [ __ ] like that he'll get like
he'll confront them if it goes down so
it'll be interesting to see how the two
of them get along yeah
actually I'll give my dad instructions
to not let racist jokes fly by him
that'll be [ __ ] real interesting dude
oh my God
someone said it's not that the racism
it's funny it's the fact that he is an
unte teachable Boomer
yeah I mean I don't think he's actually
a racist I think he's just
uh terminally
uh he's got Lee brand terminally Boomer
yeah he's a terminal Boomer terminally
terminally terminally yes all right well
thanks Jimmy for the call that was
pretty interesting that was great
let's move on to a fun segment we've got
here today
um oh no
you guys huh Austin McBroom canceled
this fight I just yeah I know this is
like breaking but you guys all had
tickets for that
uh we had digital tickets 20 off extra
oh right let's go get some refunds but
unfortunate news this morning for my
team I don't know how to feel right now
I'm sad frustrated pissed off
all I could really say is that it has
nothing to do with me or social gloves
but the fight
off you know what he's a scammer
I had a little faith redeemed at him and
now that's all gone I lasted about you
know what seven days it's all gone I'm
more compelled to believe that because
he didn't say it wasn't me and it wasn't
social gloves last time and because I
guess right now I'm on the train of
Defending Ace fam
um because right now maze found strong
right uh I'm more inclined to think that
maybe he's saying his opponent backed
out but I can't that's what he is trying
to say right to me when he's like has
nothing to do with social gloves that
made me think you think scam yeah who
the [ __ ] gonna put on an event for his
company
that bankrupted and didn't pay anyone
last time it's insane
okay but the fight
Austin first give May potentially have
to be postponed
out of respect for gim imma let him
explain his situation he has no choice
I'm gonna make a video and explain to
you guys why the fight may have to be
postponed if he doesn't do that then
I'll have no choice other than to tell
you guys what happened
as of right now the team wants me to
continue on with the event they want me
to pick a new opponent but again out of
respect forgive out of respect for us
training our asses off for the past few
months out of respect for the fans
wanting to see this fight happen I'm
willing to postpone it if he can explain
why
that's all I can't really say right now
I'm pissed off
in reality you guys got scams
I don't know Austin I'm a little
suspicious did Gibb make a statement
it's a good question let's see oh would
you fight him maybe are you two out of
shave
uh
Austin
yeah yeah yeah yeah this [ __ ]
Ace
you met him if you size them up in
person what do you think what'd you
think of his we were we were a similar
Heights surprisingly similar height yeah
because he was a basketball player I
know he probably [ __ ] me up just
because I don't have any endurance
I thought you guys were cool man you
guys are homies
yeah also I wouldn't I wouldn't feel
right punching him in the face
dude I'd love to get that going
a B versus Ace
let's make that happen [ __ ] Gibbs who
even is that guy I I don't think I'm on
the same level as him he would never
accept
I want to see us ladies and gentlemen
it's big he's got the whole H3 uh
oh he made a statement yeah juicy yo
maybe you have the whole H3 nation in
but that's true that's Cloud that's
proxy Cloud yeah yeah dude
ain't no proxy Cloud I just clout up
thank you I know yeah possibly
I was surprised hey send him a message
from the podcast and say
you'd have like 10 days of training
maybe yeah would you do it though for
real if he was like I'm down
I do it for the meme I do it for the
show but I would definitely get my ass
beat yeah I don't want you okay no no no
no no no okay I want to get my eyes I
wouldn't win but
I mean it'd be sick though like you
stopped you haven't been still training
since the event right like you you
haven't I've been not in the gym but I
haven't okay yeah
I've actually been training lean a
little bit oh yeah we've been training
so I retain the information yeah
what do you guys have a punching bag at
home we got just the two little uh what
you want to call it
what the hell they call gloves
yeah myths mitts
maybe [ __ ] do it
[ __ ] it tweet at Alston from the podcast
and say what's up [ __ ] baby will [ __ ]
you up yeah what about if it's like if
the event is going to be canceled if all
else fails and it's going to happen
a b constappen yeah and then when we
sell tickets we'll be like uh yo and by
the way you also get free tickets to
mine in ELO's wedding yeah
Ethan's next fight
H3 Fest yeah Austin's gonna suck a fat
donut dude yeah you about to suck a fat
[ __ ] donut [ __ ]
yo okay someone tweet at him
somebody make some tweets maybe it
doesn't want to do this right oh you're
just I feel like well first of all he
would never accept it's not gonna happen
he would never accept I would do it but
he will never he's not gonna accept
just for the memes okay in that case
also that's my boy but what if he did
bro that would be pretty epic anyway
here's Gibb let's see what he has to say
buenos dias ladies and gentlemen it's
big gibber here
10 days
fight we 've won Austin Broome July 30th
in the crypto Arena
I've done my training camp I've worked
hard I'm bite ready I'm primed to fight
this individual
but unfortunately I've Been Told
I have to do more Medicals for this to
be sanctioned as a profile out in L.A
so in seven hours I'm gonna fly to LA to
do these said medicals
Social Clubs have informed me that the
fight is not canceled
is postponed
I'll keep you guys updated
and this is not oversight
this is not it's just a publicity stunt
kind of this Austin's didn't seem seem
genuine like whether or not he's being
truthful about the circumstances aside
but like it didn't seem like a stunt but
this one this is done see him because he
says he's going to LA to do some yeah I
don't know you know what happened they
probably didn't sell any [ __ ] tickets
uh like for sure who's paying for this
[ __ ] right yeah and also they they're
doing at the crypto.com arena that's
where the Lakers play there's like I
that's a huge Arena yeah they are not
filling that out hell no I don't even
know what the [ __ ] Gibbs is bruh
look at these Goons
ain't nobody buying tickets to this
if if I did fight him though I would
shave my facial hair and make my hair
look exactly like his oh that's that'd
be dub the broccoli assassin yeah maybe
I'm trying to find the picture of you
that we all memed on were like that they
used for promotion where you were trying
to look intimidating in your living room
yeah the shirt I was gonna tweet that
picture at well let's get it up here we
go bro he's like he's really that's that
weirdo from the meet and greet
oh yeah he dabbed me up I thought we
were dogs
ultimate betrayal
I think sadly is just a promotional
scheme because they didn't sell any
tickets
this ain't a game this ain't a joke I'm
for real
which means that you guys are still
probably gonna see the fight
I hope so
oh God someone gave 100 bucks for you
for your birthday by the way
uh dark hole dark hole dark hole 96. oh
for me give this to my man cam happy
birthday hundred buck aruno thank you
very much
thank you that's nice of you appreciate
that
um
okay if if Austin wants to be in the uh
Creator Clash too I'm down
I'll do it that way for sure yeah but
he's got that ego he's needed to be the
headline yeah so wait are you in Creator
Clash too
or is it undecided
I uh at this time I am yes oh you are in
Creative classes you confirm what okay
that's interesting and do you know I can
do that I don't know if I am jumping the
gun with saying it publicly but yes well
why not why not get the hype going okay
yes but wait you have so this time you
have a year to prepare right yeah and do
you know who's your opponent hopefully
someone that doesn't have a
Channel called muscle party
[Music]
[Laughter]
I'm not sure yet though I'd like to
watch you beat someone's ass yeah I'm
not going to go up the party sorry
I was gonna say I'm not going up and
wait this time it'd be someone close to
my normal weight that makes a lot more
sense too so you don't know gorging on
Donuts the week before
well it was a lot of fun watching you
last time with our
our watch party that was great yeah
okay ab's back going back in the rain
if you I think if you got someone who's
actually your weight you'd slaughter
them
I mean I don't want to get too cocky but
in the gym I was pretty good against
people my size
let's go dude
oh yeah a b yeah this doesn't make you
sound like a douche
there you go a b back in the ring
they call him the fighting Arab
hello Jim Jimmy Lee uh yeah they've got
him
the Arabian Barbarian the right hand yo
that's not bad yeah well that's exciting
news
um
also I guess let's just take over the
top of the chart this uh dock here our
girl Papa party till that like it's the
it but like it's the last day I'm alive
dropped a new banger
what the [ __ ] is this
well I've never seen a video in this
resolution
what the [ __ ] is it maybe just did it
just Auto pick it to a little can you
not really no it's like that
no see it goes up oh no but the the
framing of it is oh yeah yeah you're
talking about the aspect ratio yeah the
aspect ratio is nuts uh yeah well this
is a very cinematic music video they
decided to shoot it in uh
IMAX yeah IMAX performance like IMAX
form widescreen all right let's see Amy
be baby for defense yo okay let's keep
it PG here did anyone screen this yeah
uh yeah I think I mean there's dancing
scantily Cloud women
[Music]
are they playing with pool noodles
that's an epic prop
s
[Music]
all right cool concept I like the other
one better
the video with the pig and then the
Oktoberfest is that what it is those
dresses Yeah well yeah right I mean
traditional
German outfits I can do a whole three
minutes of that really yeah
still better than Cobra Tate yeah that's
true
I just didn't see that going good should
I should I keep going I just felt if
you're not vibing with it you're not
vibing with it I don't know
um
[Music]
oh thank you also great little me Marino
uh a wedding party in Hawaii
got slammed after a tropical storm
[Applause]
you wonder how people die in tsunamis
your boots
this thing was just ready to be taken
out to sea
wow that sucks
she was angry that day my friends
[Laughter]
the waves were up to 20 feet high that
day
wow yeah this guy with the pink pants in
the top Polo was just like take me God
take me
[Music]
yeah it's kind of hard though in the
ocean itself like is this just a little
water or is this a tsunami that's going
to kill me right now yeah
like it could have easily been
a tsunami that killed everyone
[Music]
well happy marriage to them here's AB oh
everybody get on this hey Austin McBroom
I heard you need a new opponent just
saying
bro that's not what I told you to write
oh what I said
I said what's up [ __ ] oh you want me to
be way more aggressive
it's fine it's already up okay
you're a bunch of places also you didn't
tag me so I didn't I don't Cloud it up
yeah
or maybe I put it another way you're a
bunch of [ __ ] wait what does that
sound like dude who's he calling [ __ ]
uh it's in uh I think it was during the
uh Jan January 6th committee
he's calling the committee [ __ ] no no
no he was like referencing something and
um
oh guys I have a crazy update for you
I get a random DM from my best friend
Jeff whittak my best my best bud bestie
yeah
and he says
Tana Mike and I want to come on the
podcast
I was like no that's a bonanza I'm down
he just texted me but but basically I
guess Mike's out of town and then when
he comes back we'll make it happen
okay
BFFs podcast that's going to be kind of
a wild ride eh
I'm very excited that's going to be
interesting you know I'm down I'm down
to chat with them
I like Mike I think that he has
redeeming characteristics
Tana
I mean we love Tana it's all that's so
old that's whatever beef there is is
under the bridge a good damn
conversation began and Mike's my best
friend I mean I couldn't say a bad word
about him yeah
you should know your best friend's name
his name's Jeff number okay I misspoke
so that's kind of an exciting thing to
look forward to huh guys
I don't know if it's going to be like a
three-man if they're going to gang up on
me just like three verse one but I can
deal with it I can handle it
yeah handle yourself three verse one
though they're gonna Dogpile my ass
you've got us if you need us
right I got my crew I got my crew behind
my back yeah
so that's kind of insane right pretty
fun people are saying I should bring
Oliver on now now if you want chaos
you've got it
holy [ __ ]
come on you guys know that that would be
awesome
anyway I'm actually really excited about
that so that'll be fun
um you might you guys might have beef
with my best friend Jeff you guys were
saying he would think it might be a
little awkward for Dan
because you're kind of a Jeff hater Dan
for me yeah I don't give a [ __ ]
he's my best friend so you [ __ ]
should keep your mouth shut I'd like to
get to the bottom of Mike's gym shorts
oh and you want him doing some beef with
Mike maybe you guys need a square up too
yeah
it's gonna be all kinds of interesting
uh
no me and Olivia ortana stands you guys
like that high school yeah
none of us have any we all love tanning
here which is why can someone please
tell me the proper pronunciation of her
last name Mojo Mojo oh it's a Mojo Mojo
Mojo was that fresh on I think so I
thought it was
mongoose
nah that's not how I read it I'm gonna
say mama so I'm a Mamba
foreign
I just remembered that happen
I'd rather forget yeah I tried to forget
just I had a uh let's clip it out of the
episode and ruin the audio sync
I had a what do you call it intrusive
thought
[ __ ] Jimmy Lee he's being he's texting
me he's being very apologetic okay what
do you say you can relay it he's like I
don't want any hate I love you guys just
want to be fun and off the rails okay
please
you don't have to try so our gym and we
just want the real thing
I think is I like I said I think his
buddies being there that was a bad
influence they they knew him for 20 30
years these are like his these are his
boys he thinks he can get weird and wild
yeah and now he's trying to impress them
yeah yeah so Jimmy will call me uh at
like five in the morning our time which
is three hours ahead for him and I'll I
won't even be up yet and he'll just
he'll pick up the I'll pick up the phone
and he'll just start playing piano
and start doing parody songs that's
awesome he's actually really good on
piano he always does uh cover songs
which are pretty funny but I don't I
can't play him because we'll get claimed
but he's a piano man he's a piano man uh
he's played in a band for a little bit
um
yeah so you answer the phone and the
piano's going he doesn't say anything no
warning straight piano
good [ __ ] all right let's play smell my
fun girl guys in honor of Dan
uh how this is gonna work here is we
have a curtain here is there a camera
that can see this yeah
we have a curtain here and Dr fungur Who
will be played by Sam
will be sitting behind the curtain one
by one each crew member will come
and stick their finger through the
curtain
and get a smell put on their fungur
I thought I was gonna be smelling your
fungus soon
there's something grotesque about
smelling someone else's finger
well it's going to be a grotesque what
you're smelling so on your own fungus
why don't you smell what everybody would
we can reach over and stick oh that's
good I can collab with you guys yeah
yeah yeah yeah that sounds fun so
someone's gonna dump their finger in a
mystery goo
and has to guess what the scent is at
the end we will Crown the fungur
champion
uh each person will guess one smell
so you could so this is you guys mix two
things together most most of the mystery
jars have two things in them so you can
if you smell one thing more than the
other you can guess and you can get a
point per substance but all of them have
up to two there's one there's only one
that has one substance I think now why
did you mix two did you think it'd be
too easy yeah yeah I thought I thought
most of them would be a little too easy
with just one so okay so we have two
cents in one jar
one point for guessing one two points
for guessing two
right and um I'm actually just so you
are aware why Ethan I'm gonna take the
monitor off the screen because uh that
way people could cheat we don't want
them to see what's on their side so
certainly not oh you're also going to be
blind also we have um
we have an amazing little intro Stinger
for this segment as well one of my
favorites
all right smell my finger everyone
thank you
[Music]
foreign
wow we're actually going to be boxing
that and selling it on Amazon like the
You Don't Know Jack thing right just
little vials of Horrid smelling
substances to play with your friends
alright well first up is Dan
uh yeah okay I'll go first
smell my finger the legendary Dan
himself the original funker Master Dan
how are you feeling I'm feeling so ready
for this I've got my
blew my nose a few minutes ago to get
ready your nasal passages are feeling
clean how's your sense of smell in
general
to tell you the truth I have a really
bad sense of smell okay it's not it's
not very sensitive
um so you have kind of like sinus issues
and stuff you know growing up I did
actually uh I used to get sinus
infections uh like all the time
um as an adult it stopped
um but maybe it did some permanent
damage or something I don't know okay
interesting yeah well uh Sam what's
behind the curtain we have a mystery
funga sauce Dan's gonna blindfold
himself so he can't see the substance I
guess so yeah I mean we have the curtain
but I guess this is the blindfold
necessary it seems a little Overkill
yeah
um well if you look at your finger you
may be able to tell you something sticky
all right so here
you could you could maybe just pull your
beanie down over your eyes too inventive
all right Dan is blindfolded let insert
your finger through the curtain please
okay right there yeah a little to the
left there you go I'll guide you all
right now
now Dan's fonger is behind the curtain
it's being funny two fingers deep oh my
God there's a lot going on back there I
don't like this yeah that's pretty not
so potential good yeah I'll show to the
camera if you could please
pretty gnarly
I already smelled my hair oh it's like
dripping yeah there's so so go ahead Dan
yeah it's dripping down it's so big
that's a healthy dunk
that's a healthy dunk I have to give you
a good sample yeah no it's important to
do that so Dan you've picking up any uh
[Music]
you picking up any uh layers there I am
oh this is gonna be harder than I
thought
um
I this seems like too simple but maybe I
shouldn't think about this too much but
it it's it smells a little peanutty
as like a part of it
but I mean obviously it's mixed with
something else and
oh
go ahead Dan what's your final verdict
it's not good
what does the fungir tell you
it smells like cat [ __ ] uh chat and just
[ __ ] make me dip my finger in your
cat's feces did you no no no no so go
ahead you have two guests oh man I I
foreign
I think it's peanut butter and something
but
I'm not confident about your blindfolded
then maybe what do you think now we got
white substance and a granola looking
thing oh
it's cat food isn't it that's why it
smells like cat [ __ ] it is I was onto
something in ranch oh cat food and Ranch
it is Fancy Feast pate and Ranch wow
you want a piece of this nope where did
you get peanut butter from
peanut butter it's like the the texture
was kind of like crunchy peanut butter
um there are we did not prepare for them
we did we did somebody stole the wipes
yeah there were wipes over here oh there
you go here you go Clorox too we got a
you gotta have something so so Dan got
the zero point zero points Holyfield all
right thank you Dan uh do you think
you're gonna smell this fungur you know
what okay
laughs
that is so [ __ ] up that's really bad
but wait one of them is ranch right I
think that one seems obvious to me I
think the the cat the cat food was
completely overpowering the ranch smell
because I really only now that I know
what it is I was definitely smelling cat
food well um listen Dan the funker
champion is uh
because I I really did think it smelled
like cat [ __ ] and
well unfortunately
um um oh if there's no do-overs and uh
smell my finger but thank you Dan
[Applause]
zero points though and Olivia's up next
now Olivia
um
joining us here today
welcome to the show now Olivia how's
your sense of smell
um I did have covid about a month and a
half ago two months ago okay so that
affect your sense of smell you think you
know what sometimes I think so and
sometimes I think no okay okay okay
okay and how's your nasal passages today
go ahead and apply the blindfold please
oh right and uh Olivia yours is a little
interactive so you can pick some pick
something up if you feel so okay all
right here I'll see what feels good
Olivia's fastening her
her blindfold now go ahead with your
fingers through the curtain please there
it is Olivia Olivia please stand up now
her finger is being dunked as we as I
see two fingers deep just like tan uh
try to get that in there a little more
get a little yeah get a little chunk in
there so she's got a chunk yeah okay
there you go that's good that's good go
ahead pull that out there you can put
and you can pull the whole thing out
bring it to us I'll take it with you
grab it take it with me take what with
me
Olivia oh
I don't know so so Olivia's holding a
chunk of something
oh I know the smell smelling deeply
show it to the people turn your hand
around yeah there you go it smells Smoky
kind of like beef jerky
or dog food
okay she's processing it smells like a
dog tree okay so do you have any guesses
here there's two ingredients in terms of
texture
I'm feeling
[Music]
almost marshmallow like
but not quite move your hands a little
bit to your left please yeah finger
um
I'm gonna say
dog food marshmallow Okay okay go ahead
take your blindfold off
so that looks [ __ ] disgusting
let me take a look at that is that a hot
dog I feel sick that would be a hot dog
in school glue glue you all are crazy
back there
[Applause]
it's [ __ ] up Sam what are you doing
I don't think I think one cent would
have been hard enough but I like the two
it's disgusting it makes it well you can
you do get a point if you guess one or
the other or both I got zero so Olivia
with a hot dog and glue does that shock
you Olivia
um
it shocks me because that's totally not
what I thought it was right right
um they were on a good track see thank
you
you were on a good track there I mean
thank you that's what I felt too yeah I
thought I was going somewhere sausage I
was hoping you would eventually find hot
dog but you know what I'm wondering is
there gelatin in hot dogs
the way that like horse Hooves we don't
know what's in there yeah who knows
what's in it though incredible it's
interesting to think you thought the hot
dog was a marshmallow though right that
is fascinating I did not come on my door
I want to know the psychology behind
that well Olivia was zero points We
Salute You two fungus salute
but uh unfortunately
zero points to uh Olivia who we love so
well up next a b
[Applause]
a b e joining us today smell my fun girl
ladies and gentlemen
welcome baby nice to have you on the
show thank you happy to be here how's
your smile how to smell it dude uh it's
usually pretty good uh my nose has been
a little clogged since I moved out here
it's the air is like super dry compared
to Michigan okay he's blamingo on the
city yeah blaming down the city you
lived here for a year yeah still blaming
the city almost two years actually
almost two years yeah yeah can you talk
a little closer with Mike please yeah
yeah okay but but um you're feeling
confident it seems like the smell here
potentially yeah okay let's go ahead and
dip those fingers folks hunger up to the
left a little bit there's the curtain
okay good so a b is performing the two
finger dunk
oh get deep Diva here you can grab a
little chunk too if you want just hey
you have some
all right
how does it feel yeah do you want to
describe the sensation it feels Haram
doesn't feel right so bring it out show
the people to give it a smell here now
first show it to the folks at home okay
good excellent
all right go in for a sniff look not
good
[Music]
hold on
[Music]
a b o a b is wretching
Sam if
Sam
If part of this is garlic
that bad she knows I hate garlic I think
she knows she made it there's I there's
no garlic in that there's no garlic that
I know of wow because garlic is such a
unique smell to think uh you could get
something like that wrong yeah I don't
know it's [ __ ] god-awful okay I have
no clue what it is so or do you want to
make any guesses at all
foreign
[Music]
take off your blindfold baby yeah so
it's a little brown and a little white
oh it looks like nut when I open my eyes
uh Mayo
and Taco Bell quesadilla sauce that's
interesting guys it is actually Taco
Bell ground beef whoa
whoa yeah maybe interesting that you
picked that up but but zero nonetheless
yes well I guess
I know I'm just gonna say maybe that was
pretty close I got them nope listen
listen the rules are the rules okay
thank you thank you uh that's a zero
listen you guys didn't get Grace damn
you're a harsh judge well he took his
blindfold off at that point it's over oh
I see yeah his blind yeah yeah I was
looking at it thank you somebody said
there's garlic in Taco Bell seasoning
maybe yeah a little hint of garlic
garlic I mean
yeah maybe I got we got some mayo and
ground beef on the
mic there Mike is gonna smell good well
I'll tell you what this game is turning
out harder than we anticipated because a
b
with zero points thanks for taking a
dunk buddy
[Applause]
a b taking a dunk
and getting zero points well up next
it's the birthday boy himself
everybody knows him everybody loves him
it's Cameron
welcome to the show Cameron how's your
sense of smell here buddy it's pretty
good I think you know coming to
confident well everyone else has zero
points so let me put this on you know
people think I smoke weed at my desk all
the time because I got that fumes coming
up but that's just an oil diffuser I'm a
big smells fan so we love smells here
yeah so hold on let me take my rings off
okay he's taking his rings off he's you
know getting serious keeping them clean
yeah all right camera only rings go
ahead and slide your hand through the
curtain on the left there a little bit
Cameron
we got two fingers going into a jar oh I
don't like this yeah that looks nice
that looks real nice it feels pretty
gnarly bring it on out here please okay
show to the people at home
yeah yeah good all right here let me
move the mic out of the way for you
[Music]
yeah interesting he's not wretching
yeah yeah
m is confidently sniffing he's wondering
not wretching
picking up any notes there it's it's
familiar but I can't okay okay okay
they say smell is the closest sense tied
to memory
yeah where does this punch is it uh is
there like cake batter in it or
something egg batter you have a second
guess for the second ingredient
soup I got on my lap yeah you were
getting pretty close there here's a
paper towel thank you very much
[Music]
second guess
I don't know I'm gonna go for the joke
because I can't tell cake better and
come I don't know cons
coming into the jar nobody I just want
to make it all right cake batter and
come take off your blindfold
Sam it actually is nut all right uh it's
Ian's uh
um it is chocolate syrup and sardines oh
man
where does that bring you to I don't
know if something is familiar coming up
on the chocolate obviously that's yeah
that's that's what I thought the Sardine
smell at all I yeah I was trying to
that's why I couldn't place it I just
couldn't tell it was overpowered by the
chocolate that's wild oh do you want one
of these oh yeah
that's even better
oil diffuser oh bringing up the smells
too hit that oh that's nice vanilla
apple apple wow wonderful all right
thank you uh Cameron happy birthday
buddy happy birthday coming in with zero
points there
a fierce competitor
zero points wow next up we have this is
hard as [ __ ]
everybody's favorite
Lena come on out here to smell my fun
girl
Lena ladies and gentlemen
is going to take the plunge the fingers
are going to be dipped Lena thank you
for joining us thanks for having me and
how's your sense of smell you believe in
it yeah hopefully better than everyone
else's yeah yeah yeah yeah
okay good we'll go ahead and put strap
the blindfold and we're going to dunk
your fingers straight into a Unknown
Subject it turns on your left a little
bit there there it is right there push
through Lena yours is actually just one
cent okay so hey Lena gets one cent
hopefully I get the point
does she get two points if she gets yes
yes yeah okay so she's taking the plunge
oh that's so interesting
yeah it's like a fluffy should be good
um no she didn't pull anything out just
do anything no you didn't need to pull
anything out okay can I actually can I
get it
um
you yeah a little it may make kind of a
mess but okay Lena is a fierce
competitor she's going back
to pull it out
well that's interesting yeah it's kind
of hard to pull out maybe just grab the
jar yeah you can just take the whole
time yeah
okay Lena has the whole jar
going forward oh my God that is so weird
that is so
by weird what do you mean is it gross is
it odd what are we thinking gross but
like
[Music]
rotting rotting yeah
yeah I'm impressed you haven't wretched
like your husband he immediately went
into the shirt
I just I have to smell it too
you you may want to pull the blindfold
up a little bit I don't know if that
matters to you oh he's covering yourself
right that's right that'll help you
[Music]
oh I don't know and it's like spongy
like cotton I don't know who's breathing
deeply of the substance this one's more
about what it smells like versus the
substance don't worry about the subject
I'll be straight with you what you're
holding is it looks just like cotton
okay it is it's just cotton it's just a
smell it's kind of a confusing texture
there what are you thinking Lena I don't
know of some kind of liquid uh
like uh
is it I don't know it's so hard to point
because it's kind of girl it's like
something you'd smell in a bathroom go
ahead it's not okay okay
it's not human fecal matter right we
wouldn't I don't know it's a great guess
but no
is it uh
along those lines something to do with
paint maybe I don't think it's toxic no
no all right Lena hey you're gonna have
to give a guess okay I'll say pink
thinner paint thinner my goodness out
here killing brain cells yeah
go ahead take off your blindfold reform
maybe I feel like I know what it is from
here let me take a guess is it fika fish
oh no it's not oh [ __ ] smell it
no it may smell similar hi fart bomb
right yep it is
something from the bathroom though yeah
you were yeah yeah I think Parts dude I
feel like I I feel like you could get a
point yeah for what I'm saying it smells
away from the bathroom that's like one
of the closer guests guess was paint
thinner you're right you guys are yeah I
mean I get fart bomb though I've never
smelled a fart bomb
if you would have said like poop or fart
or something like that then I would have
human people listen uh Lena we love you
you tried your best you were close at
one point but listen the answer you you
submitted was was not bathroom uh but
but uh but we appreciate the effort and
and incredible that you didn't even
wretch because that's probably the worst
smelling thing I had to keep smelling
too I thought this was one of the worst
ones yeah that's vile well uh Lena
excellent Valiant effort thank you for
joining us here smell the fun girl
we love that I prepared her for this
segment Lena everybody
bomb
uh you guys wanted to give her the point
but guys this is not serious this is a
serious competition please I just got it
all over my hands
um that is smells so wretched that was a
that was a cruel one for Paulina
it's it's a bad one well Lena uh so far
zero points for everybody
uh Zach is up next people are pointing
out she did guess cotton at one point
which is technically true no she said if
she doesn't know I told her it was
caught
he did I told her it was caught okay
Zach
oh the sound just stops oh
oh my God I smell it I'm smelling the
fart spray from here
[Music]
Zach joining us welcome to smell my
finger the audio when Zach gets up prop
it up some say Zach is the best sound
man in the game thank you oh I smell
that [ __ ] farts I say he's the only
sound man in the game everyone else
doesn't exist thank you I appreciate
that Zach how you feeling how's your
sense of smell pretty good haven't had
coveted yet knock on wood okay
um so well I've heard that before and
nobody's got a point so let's see if
Zach can pull through we got the Zach go
ahead and fasten your your blindfold
and when you're ready you can reach your
fingers through the curtain stick in my
right right there buddy yeah okay now
let's just get those two or one finger
two one or two with this one you can you
can get a little a little bit of this
Sam is suggesting you take some chunks
with you because it's got like a cottage
cheese I hope if you if you will
okay ooh what are you thinking this is
gross me out yeah it looks pretty gnarly
from here yeah Cottage I wish we had a
camera do we have a shot of the star oh
that's good yeah we do good because I
can't see you guys yeah although there's
not really a possibility to cheat
because they're blindfolded oh that's so
gnarly that shot it's okay all right
Zach enough you've been fingering that
thing too long here take a chunk with
you it's a good time it's a great thing
there you go it brings like happy
tapioca you know all right go ahead show
to the audience if you would please
yeah yeah go ahead take some Snips there
watch out for them
appreciate that yeah nice Rolex by the
way thank you oh you dripped on it no
I'm just kidding don't even [ __ ] with me
like that man
got like a Cheesy smell okay cheesy okay
I'm just they know I don't like a
certain thing so I'm just gonna go off
the bat and say this is there Greek
yogurt in this you cannot no stop
Sam don't answer that question okay
never mind never mind
I mean this is a serious competition you
guys are destroying the Integrity of
it's true smell my fungus there's a lot
on the line here what's on the what do
you win [ __ ] the smoke like funker
Champion bro stick your thunder champ
Prestige okay
go ahead I'm gonna go cottage cheese all
right
and some type of tuna oh interesting
okay Tuna take off your blindfold Sam
that is blue cheese and applesauce
okay I mean cottage cheese you were you
know dude geez you were you were close
maybe I think that's the point that's
maybe a cheese the cheese sauce I'm
thinking is maybe we can give them a
point on that one yeah I'll give you a
point wow thank you no one's had a point
yet however I'm gonna have to deduct a
point for the Greek yogurt answer if you
have zero points oh come on I'm kidding
congratulations wow is on the scoreboard
holy crap congratulations uh smell my
funker Champion you should just use the
same it's a good probably a good call
these are bleach wipes or not I like the
bleach is there bleach in those yeah
this is Clorox wipe oh my bad I know
there's a bleach
Chris lemon
oh it says bleach free
but there's something going on with
these
it's a little extra people are demanding
that we give them the point we are I
gave him a point yeah
Zach is on the scoreboard with one point
wow ladies and gentlemen
the smell King perhaps
what just happened you erased a name
yeah I realized I had Ian in there but
Ian can't play he knows what they all
are oh okay okay so maybe we'll have a
tiebreaker yeah so it's my turn yeah so
maybe we'll be going to the tiebreaker
let me go head to head with Zach we
might go into overtime
congratulations Zach thank you the only
one on the scoreboard I'll be going up
next
I'll be sitting in the fungus seat
myself welcome to the ship
[Music]
[Applause]
I'm in the hot seat ladies and gentlemen
now as far as my sense of smell goes I
think I have a good sense of smell but
thank you now but I did have kovid
recently I completely lost my sense of
smell like 100 I could not smell a thing
I'm pretty sure I've gotten most of my
smell back
my passages Feel clean I feel confident
and ready to do this uh Sam I'm
inserting my fingers behind the curtain
is it what does it feel like like what
do you experiencing okay interesting
this one you can take a little chunk
with you too if you want to get a little
something for the road
I think they feel pretty coated okay
yeah no you're good
[Music]
back a little bit so you know going in
for a smell well I can smell from here
get on the blind
[Music]
oh that's a familiar smell
[Music]
what is that
[Music]
hahaha
[Music]
dude I think I know what it is yeah
[Music]
oh my god dude there's such weird smells
battling each other right now
bro you guys are gonna trip but I think
I know what they both are okay
I think it's marinara sauce and black
beans holy [ __ ]
that's wrong
did I get any of those right it's like
ridiculously close yeah it's interesting
I'm wondering I feel like maybe
oh it's pesto and and Bush's Baked Beans
and baked beans so on both counts you
were like one step away the smells were
there yeah I think I could give you a
point for beans
yeah I mean you did say beans yeah it's
beans okay wow oh I was so close esto of
course it was so familiar you should be
very familiar with pesto yeah right yeah
I get it so wait do we have two more
well I think we need I think we need a
timer I think you get one point I think
you and Zach Head to Head wow the smell
King the gauze is in the office I gotta
go and that's not anti-semitic it's just
well we are both Jews roll that back
thanks I said it's not Annie Smith the
bands have he's okay I'm a happy the
wrong half he's the Half Blood Prince
um
thank you everybody I'm gonna go rinse
my hands Zach come join us yeah Zach
come on down
you'll have to be uh the first of the
second round here
[Music]
uh Zach is having an interaction with
Ethan asking for the blindfold as Ethan
goes he's coming on down Zach has now
successfully grabbed that come on down
and he's walking to his chair oh and
he's taking a seat good to be back over
to Dan with the weather
[Music]
back to you Olivia
Zach is having some sort of trouble when
it comes to time what up baby that was
that was that wasn't
that wasn't a Jew joke by the way this
is yeah you get a person exactly date
look this is date Zach inspired by uh
Michael Scott's [ __ ] you baby Mike you
just can't rock it dude all right we're
back at the world championship the final
showdown between Zach and myself the
smell of champions of the office
interestingly both of us were not
exactly right but close enough no I'm
thanks bro respect respect game
recognized game that's right
now get I recommend giving your fingers
a pretty smell to make sure the previous
smell is gone
it's still cheesy even though I scrubbed
okay
um but try to block that out yeah yeah
okay so Zach is basically here fingers
in
for the final showdown
two fingers deep
you can take a little chunk that cause
feeling oh it's like
what is that consistency I know that
okay pull pull it out for the folks at
home
okay no no show that oh whoa okay I
don't know I gave something away there
but I'm just shocked by the color and
consistency of that
[Music]
Zach is rolling in between his fingers
give it a smell
[Music]
okay holy [ __ ] now I noticed Zach
keeping it a healthy distance from his
face I don't want to get it on my
[ __ ] nose absolutely
I wouldn't either
that's [ __ ]
straight up [ __ ] man I don't think
that's allowed by the rules it's not
[ __ ] no human feces I'll just give you
that oh my God this is the championship
so Focus your mind
[Music]
go ahead
[Music]
I know this consistency time to give an
answer Zach oh [ __ ] me
two guesses
he's really rolling it between his
fingers like Matthew McConaughey I don't
drive him like a little rim on your not
like just you want me to put it on my
nose yeah just like rub it no just to
get the smell better you know
all right we need a gas Zach
God that's awful go ahead now uh
I'm gonna see
Greek yogurt
and
[Music]
putty of some sort putty like like silly
silly putty yeah Zach says Greek yogurt
and silly putty go ahead take your
blindfold off that's [ __ ] that's [ __ ]
[ __ ] dude
that the smell profile is a rotten egg
oh but it is actually a preserved duck
egg and so it that's it's just one
that's it oh just a duck egg oh that's
rotten egg yeah well you were actually
saying it [ __ ] it's [ __ ] I I feel like I
should get that point probably not that
bad of a guess yeah we'll have to see
which you guys I think to call it this
looks like [ __ ] I I mean let me smell it
I mean I feel like I agree he was pretty
close by just saying he thought it was
[ __ ] because that that would probably
smells similar
but he ultimately landed on Greek
actually to be honest I do smell a
little egg in there you smell egg I do
like a sulfur smell no like just egg
egg
all right well Zach thank you nice that
was a tough one I'm not gonna lie but
this is the championship so yeah both of
the finals are just one item I believe
okay right so Ethan it's up to you to
see if you can wow so this is for the
two points so this is a mega win this is
a huge win all right Zaki was unable to
score a point
I'm going to be coming in to the hot
seat
I'll be applying the blindfold
[Music]
everything is on the line
I will be crowned the fungal champion
if I can get this here today
leaving you
Sam are you ready for my fungus
I'm ready insert the fungus here they
are
okay oh God that feels so [ __ ] up
that texture is nuts wait whoa whoa whoa
bring it back
I haven't oh my God what is that okay
oh dude no
bro what the [ __ ] is this Sam
[Music]
did Dan move away from me
did Dan still there
he moved because it smells that bad
who's this
that's Dan
no it's not yeah
[Music]
bro what the [ __ ] Sam
that's obviously FICA fish
that is uh correct that is correct it is
FICA fish
that's so gross dude
hell nah bruh
yeah it hit me and I had to dip or I was
gonna puke on camera
oh oh it's so strumming ladies and
gentlemen cleared out the room yeah
there's a lot of people who overreact on
YouTube not us you got to smell this
[ __ ] in real life to see oh yeah Olivia
is uh is wretching oh I'm getting away
with the room it's starting to walk over
here dude how are you like sir oh you
have a mask on yeah you could have
brought one for all of us like I was
saying I'm not dying
holy so like that was another brand of
Sue strumming it wasn't it that was was
that a different one yeah
I wonder if it's worse did you meet
Jesus Christ steal it Sam or is it still
filling the room no no it's it was just
in a jar it's not open nothing's open
okay
I don't smell it anymore over here
actually
oh oh okay nice maybe I'm just used to
it
I did have to open it outside earlier
and it got on my hands
Jesus
I've been suffering in the back right
now yeah well Ethan wins he got it right
he won but what at what cost
I guess to be fair to the other
competitors I I don't I think everyone
would have got that one right yeah
you know it's true that is that is
probably an easy one but I'm not gonna
hold it against you at all because you
yeah it's punishment enough to have to
do that the worst part was that
I really fished my fingers in there yeah
my sense when you pulled it away that
maybe you were trying to do me a favor
you didn't need to take a chunk with you
because the thing is I was really
fishing around to feel the texture of it
and I got it under my nails and [ __ ] oh
the waft over here is insane you were
fishing around all right
and I got a prize when did you open that
can
uh or earlier this morning
so you opened it outside it's just in um
one of these it's in here oh okay okay
so I had to open it and put one piece in
there that's crazy that you opened it
Jarred it and then briefly open the jar
and the effect I just when I went to
wash my hands people were running away
from the set
Ting up I just saw her running away
[Laughter]
oh my God
I feel bad every time you guys bringing
the fika fish
um into the studio this was just a
little it is your fault we do blame you
for being Swedish I mean it is my fault
pretty much you know yeah it's under my
nails dude what the [ __ ] bro
all right well well I'm the winner
congratulations wow that's why you're
the king
I am the funker champ I tip my hat to
you and let's see what I win
what do we got here
everybody
Gangsta until the Sue strumming lid pops
yo that's actually good merch bro what
are we selling this
that's fire
yes
would you guys buy this merch
[Applause]
Amazon Amazon wait what yeah I thought
for sure you guys made this because it's
so Random
okay well shout out to whoever made that
then
oh my god get that jar out of here bro
you don't be good like you you heard
people like on their enemies they do
pranks like very rotten fish she put a
can of Sue strowman in someone's house
oh yeah
dish message a sicilian message
Yeah we actually do that to [ __ ] with
people yeah that's a Swedish prank
um no not really that's too too far
that's too [ __ ] up yeah well I won but
at what cost
at what cost my dear friends the cost
was too high
Victory came at a bitter
bitter bitter price
oh
I washed my fingers so many times I
tried to get into the nails
oh [ __ ]
everyone gangster to that Sue strowman
lip pop ain't it the truth
well thank you to Sam for officiating
this
well done
well done
I'm proud though I'm a proud the proud
winner of smell my finger you should be
it's quite the accomplishment I don't
win much in life but thank you you know
I've always been proud of my sense of
smell
and I think I've proven here today that
I do have super smelling
I do close on that first one too that's
super strong having just done it I mean
it's hard like I said though I have a
terrible the thing is when you see it it
makes it way easier yeah not seeing it
it couldn't like the smells are all over
the place man
[Music]
um well how about that huh well actually
up next we have another uh
taste set tasting segment
which is pretty exciting this is right
after that it is what it is
we have a a basically a tribute to
keemstars
beef jerky syrup taste test it tastes
like beef jerky
uh keemstar was angry
out of at us for making fun of the fact
that he ate syrup with a fork
and dunk beef jerky
so
wait is this the whole thing yeah it's
at six minutes okay 15 seconds and so
today we are going to honor him
by trying what he claims you can only
get in Buffalo which is maple syrup and
beef jerky
and seeing if maybe I took the jokes too
far maybe he's on to something
um now this is like real jerky
but yeah
real maple syrup wait wait don't tell me
you take maple syrup by itself for this
what I would do is rip a little piece of
jerky exactly dip it in exactly maple
syrup that you get in the store is not
real maple syrup it's made out of corn
syrup this is real authentic maple syrup
yeah you can buy that in the store too
dude yeah they're right next to each
other
every store don't double dips man I know
you like double dipping
get that fork in there Bootsy I can't
even get used to it because it goes down
so easy it's like Smooth so smooth okay
brother talking about it like it's like
a shot of vodka
it's been around for like thousands of
years people have been eating syrup
his shoeing is so bizarre it's really
munchy and I don't know going in there
with a fork is just iconic and nobody
will convince me otherwise
you know
one more time for the people in back
it's like Smooth so smooth okay be
careful when he gets drunk because he's
gonna start chugging this my friend's
gonna start chucking the maple syrup I
already know Keith told us to change
because he said it's about to get a
little dirty so there we go there we
have it so keemstar is
frankly he's not happy
it tastes like beef jerky when did he
say that Zach
when he eats a beef jerky I didn't catch
it maybe I didn't go back far enough
because that that I love that I mean
that's just a huge great analysis
all right this is my like childhood
butcher he lives around the corner you
gotta try this okay first we're gonna do
let's do the cheese first spicy Italian
got a ton of flavor on it
Kim you ever been to a deli
foreign
you can get this [ __ ] anywhere in any
city in the whole country it's good
he's like here's some cheese with spice
on it bro
all right now this is the smoke cheese
all right you guys are big on cheese oh
I love cheese love meat like normally I
would get bread cheese and meat and one
buy it
that's something eats like a horse with
peanut butter in his mouth
foreign
one of these this is the hot cheese
pepper stuck yep
bro close your mouth okay now this is
the best this is just regular cheese
pepper stick
but you know Foos is like why you giving
me regular ass food and acting like it's
incredible
he's like what am I supposed to tell you
give me cheese
thoughts it tastes like beef jerky
that's the [ __ ] best sound but it's
so funny it doesn't be jerky
well it is
okay so so in honor of this wonderful
moment uh we've got ourselves a plate of
maple syrup
now guys is this authentic maple syrup
or is this corn syrup
Buffalo's Finest
by the way
by the way
Kim says you can't buy this anywhere
and Target uh actually
100 pure maple syrup
three bucks
no artificial flavors baby sweeteners or
colors grade a baby three bucks
Target
it's the real stuff
so bring it out here
bring it out here
oh my God what a tray
wow this now we have the meats here my
friends this is my childhood butcher
[Music]
this is kind of food you can't get
anywhere
now for let me go in for the um
let me go in for the syrup
[Music]
mmm it's so smooth
it should be jerky it's so smooth
you can just drink the whole bottle it's
so smooth
damn that's crazy huh
wow all right now I'm going to take the
beef jerky
and I'm going to defy
all expectations and dunk
the beef jerky in the syrup
this is incredible stuff here
only in Buffalo
dump that
when in Buffalo
wow wow tastes like beef jerky yeah
does it taste like Upstate New York
wow a little
now would you say that it tastes like a
Slim Jim or like a like a high quality
slim jim dude it's like a it's like a
slim jim but with good ingredients right
here's a meat stick
from my local butcher
say goodbye have you been
oh that's [ __ ] growth
that's what Lucy wanted to tell him at
one point right yeah
no what is that
is that a slim jim I think it might be
or or some or a knockoff Slim Jim or a
high quality I don't know
that's if Lucy was telling the truth
here we have a little hot dog
got this from my local butcher
was it your childhood butcher I've been
going to the same butcher since I was a
child you can't get this kind of meats
anywhere in the world
I actually do have a childhood Butcher
on ironically you don't because you have
meats that you can't find anywhere
he does actually and cheeses but it's
it's a different situation because it's
halal meat and yeah whoa while we're
talking I mean like it looks good the
stuff that he's giving
if it's just hilarious what it what it
is
[Music]
wow it tastes like beef jerky no way you
gotta make sure to eat like fousey too
right
yeah let's be super authentic here
Zach could show you how if you need help
[Laughter]
Cam's left very hard in the background
he feels my pain
hey oh and love of course
All Right Moving On
the cheese
[Music]
smoked cheddar for my childhood butcher
it's Italian for my childhood cow
yeah yo you guys love cheese or what
yeah
I usually eat cheese with bread
[Music]
and meat but not today all together it
doesn't be jerky this also tastes like
beef jerky this might be the most Petty
segment we've ever done for sure
reacted to the video too
oh God beef jerky I'm so sad that he
took it down the public deserves this
video that's what we're here for yeah
dude you get some syrup to dip in I did
not get no syrup the [ __ ] oh That's
essential it's coming the syrup's coming
the syrup's coming this is uh they're
draining she's draining it from the
maples
this is spiced uh pepper jack grown from
the sacred cow of Buffalo New York
right yeah it only can yield one
only one pepper jack cow one per year
for my childhood Butcher and it lives
only in Upstate New York it tastes like
beef jerky it tastes like beef jerky
[Laughter]
what do you think about those spices
unbelievable that she's it's got some
Flex in it looks like it's got some
spice there's some spice this is if you
can't get this anywhere bro this is only
from my local book here
wait let me hit this maple syrup again
this is too much what was funny is how
little he put on the plate I see I
should have should have been more
concerned some of this off um
with the syrup yeah there's way too much
on the plate because it was like it was
like a stingy pour yo the beef jerky
with the syrup yeah just pour it all off
it slops my guy
yo did you guys oh I I forgot about this
I mean
wow this is a cow [ __ ]
because the size of that thing yeah it's
a big one juicer mm-hmm
you can't find this anywhere
[ __ ] [ __ ]
tastes like beef jerk really
just like beef jerky
it tastes like beef jerky that's weird
because when you try it with syrup it
kind of
it like it tastes like beef jerky with
syrup right it tastes like beef jerky no
it tastes like beef jerky right
this is good though
okay there we go now this is more like
the serving keemstar gave this guy
let me put my fork in this
you can't just be giving that [ __ ] away
that's like Maple it's so smooth
it's real syrup
what's just so funny is the insinuation
that he's like treating him
to this fine cuisine roll your fork
around that dollop of syrup buddy this
is Hospitality what you think
um
[Music]
it's so smooth
and just one log of uh salami in the in
the syrup oh yeah
um
[ __ ]
[Music]
all right that was fun
everyone enjoy yeah yeah I've never had
cheese acres in my life yo how good is
that cheese bro I've never had cheese
where'd you guys get that cheese by the
flex my childhood cow what does it taste
like Dan
you know I've been vegetarian for a long
time
but with memory serves me right
it tastes like beef jerky hey it tastes
like beef jerky
oh dude this is crazy
this is awesome bro this is highest
level [ __ ]
[Music]
yeah I'm so good
someone says I know y'all meme but I
have a co-worker that orders jerky and
cheese direct from an Amish farm and
it's legit good I'm sure it's good I can
bring you guys back some beef jerky from
my hometown next time I come I would
love that me too well okay they have
syrup too they don't have syrup not a
Detroit thing uh Canada thing I could
drive to Canada just what's up only
drive across the border in Detroit yeah
you can't find beef jerky like this
anywhere
now mine's legit
nah not Buffalo legit you'll see
Bob
incredible segment
hard hitting
we love that
um oh yeah there's this other main story
we're doing
this one guy this one YouTuber who's
like uh Mr beasts Protege yeah
clone the rule of two now I I was
wondering because I remember did you
guys find those tweets of Mr Beast
talking about
um
he was coaching some random Channel and
the channel was like blowing up
[Music]
um
I totally remember that I think he must
have been talking about this guy
yeah anyway this look at this thumbnail
y'all
I this is a pretty funny tweet Mr Beast
ruined a whole generation of YouTubers
and this isn't a Christmas Mr Beast
obviously uh God bless him
but look at this [ __ ] day four
I spent a hundred hours in the world's
poorest country
here he is being swarmed by black
children and his hands are like yo no no
no too much
so but I love the insinuation that it's
like a challenge I spent 100 hours the
hundred hour challenge [ __ ] they lived
there
they were born there they lived there oh
boy
crazy like wow
crazy just wow tone deafness like whoa
dude
we're doing the Ouija board Challenge
and the face too that soy face like I've
never seen it's so scary
what's the insinuation that he just
getting swarmed by black children asking
him for [ __ ]
look at his hand it's like yeah he's in
over his head sort of like how they do
it like Orbeez and stuff like he's in a
I don't know why are they swarming him
I'm drowning I'm proud of him look at
his hand his hands are like yo back the
[ __ ] up
it's like Bianca falling off a cliff you
know yeah no I don't read it that way I
read it more like look at these
souvenirs I got on my trip yeah oh I
read it as work with me work with me
little starving kids that's actually a
Jimmy Lee's son he always talks about
it is
yep yep
my brother you mean
right
um
someone better take these meats away
from me I'm gonna keep eating it during
the show
again work with me people I'm the meat
shop
nice chunk of salami though
tastes like beef jerky
that's um
we posted this
and a lot of people
understandably
we're like dude what the [ __ ] is this
um
yeah Mr Beast put out this set of tweets
and I just it just clicked for me bro
it's got to be him
I started I started counseling a small
YouTuber for fun
and here's a monthly before and after of
their Channel
counseling that's why I couldn't find it
five million views
twenty four thousand
now
45 million views
four hundred thousand
damn son
that's some guacamole
It's gotta be him does that measure up
with this tweet
oh my God
please save me
if only I was a little starving African
boy
he would give me the world
real quick
uh
there's
some people complaining about the audio
in for real this time audio audio
uh saying it's clipping uh are you
hearing that is that I don't hear
anything there's lots of people saying
it's fine too but I'm seeing a mixed bag
audio audio is experiencing issues right
now clicking noise
there's no popping it's fine you are
really [ __ ] with Dan at this point
with the audio uh there is something I
just heard heard a click
interesting just a slight slight clip
I'm not hearing anything on my end
a lot of people say it's fine
Maybe
try refreshing if you're getting a
popping or clicking people saying it's
clipping means it's way too loud but I'm
looking at the meters right now are way
below clipping level so flipping for me
yo it's just impossible to tell if
they're yeah it's like a pulp
wait did they say clipping or clicking
because I'm hearing they were saying
clipping but uh I hear clicking and
clipping oh boy I heard a click
[Music]
no Ethan cut out for a second came back
in like real quick so it's okay now
no no I mean it's it's happening okay
it's fine but
uh we can continue probably but there's
well I'll continue and Dan will uh
troubleshoot how about that
yep yeah so
what do you think about that theory
though that this is the guy he was
talking about
because like
let's if you go back to his channel
actually if you go back this guy won a
Lamborghini foreign
take your right hand and put it on the
Lamborghini whoever takes their hand off
last gets the 300 000 so he actually won
this competition
why am I getting scared I'm gonna do it
no I'm not yes what
yeah so anyway I guess he they know each
other
also he's selling YouTube oh okay go to
YouTube course website now link care so
he's selling YouTube anniversary uh
University
whoa dude what the [ __ ]
in this video I'm going to tell you
everything you need to know about this
YouTube course you might be wondering
why I'm doing this I was a kid from a
small country named Cyprus and I
um
wow this guy's selling courses on this
it's hard to the numbers actually quite
adds up quite good It's gotta be him his
total views is 51 million and the
screenshot is 45 million yes
by the way
what I wonder what's his course on this
[ __ ] on creating a thumbnail like this
I think he has more to learn before he
starts teaching
but if you go to his channel
um
his thumbnails are insane dude look at
this
also but his views are kind of slacking
though bro
um
it's got to be him like one year ago he
was getting 69 000 views right
and then all of a sudden
with that little Mr Beast influence you
can see it comes in here
here it is
four degrees
ran 28 miles
we broke up oh excellent excellent
I think they're still together this is
how I met Eric
Eric's controlled my life for 24 hours
lots of numbers all of a sudden
hour 58
I think he went Mr Beast
it makes too much sense everything is
just like him dude it's for sure him
but I like that the the like staggering
life-changing advice he got was just
like
why about how epic [ __ ] is yeah and
making insane [ __ ] thumbnails
by the way he updated the thumbnail now
do the insinuation of spending 100 hours
in the world Sports country is still
kind of like white devil Vibes oh yeah
for sure it's like entirely white savior
but it's just like that photo I feel
like they should use it to teach people
about right being a white savior right
even this one's it's better don't get me
wrong but it's still kind of weird right
we're happy now the weird thing about it
too is that it's clearly photoshopped
like he photoshopped these kids on him
like look look how weird it is
in fact uh you can pull up the HD
thumbnail there's websites where you can
do that so we can get a better look at
it
um the change one will be able to see
the original yeah it'll show you the new
one okay just do like
I think so
I wonder if it's real because it just
looks like the contrast is pulled up way
up let's take a look yeah I think I'm
sure he photoshopped something bro
nothing in this photo makes any damn
sense isn't Discord would you say cam
what's your professional opinion
I guess so
let's look closely at this new thumbnail
I'm sorry I said let's look closely at
this thumbnail his face
it looks like it's in it it was taken in
a different place
like yeah if it's photoshopped it's just
the face from you right and then the
hand also there's like a super weird
contrast with the kid's hand oh yeah
it's yeah I think he's definitely
Photoshop his look at his face the
lighting is like completely different
yeah
cam what's your expert opinion
uh I mean it's hard to say I think it's
Photoshop yeah that's awesome
white devil
yeah but you face the face for sure
without a doubt well what yeah I mean it
was probably he took a bunch of
thumbnail option photos while he was
there and he was soy facing the [ __ ] out
of all of them and then realized that
that seemed really distasteful so
photoshopped in just like a more neutral
face instead of yeah yeah it's a face
that he was soy facing and then he took
this from somewhere else right yeah
that's my suspicion
I love the soy face with these
I can't believe all these Starving
Children
today's thumbnail that I made for this
episode is one of my favorites I've made
in a while it cracked me up
so this is Mr Beast protege
I'm almost certain about it
and uh
Mr Beast is smart he knows how to toe
the line between like
charity and fun but this [ __ ] is just
off the rails man
the video itself isn't bad right
somebody watched it it's not like super
offensive
the content of the video isn't
necessarily offensive but it's the
thumbnail that everybody had a huge
problem with yeah
um
where does he get off selling oh my God
soy Nation
nightmare blood I still don't pull off
the soy face like they do
uh
uh I don't know you pretty much look
exactly like one of the soy Jacks yeah
okay here
wait what's coming off my finger oh that
smells yeah I mean you all the details
are there
pretty much this guy all right all right
all right
okay
yeah that actually looks pretty pretty
close
dude has you ever made this L this face
in real life ever
uh yeah when a new Funko Pop dropped of
my favorite Marvel character oh
[Laughter]
I don't know where this guy gets off
doing
by the way this guy's been popular for
like six months since Mr Beast like gave
him the secret to success and now he's
selling University [ __ ]
I hate this [ __ ]
get what you need with a uni pass nft oh
it's [ __ ] go go yes
there it is we need that nft how to Mint
YouTube this video I'm going to explain
you how you can mint my nft no thanks
I am so excited
oh man keep you do you buddy I guess now
he's just having a big joke out of it
yeah this shit's crazy bro you need to
like these all these Mr beasts uh
clones need to chill a little bit
I spent 24 hours buried alive
hi all of his videos start like Mr Beast
videos too where it's just screaming at
you the second the video starts let's
see
it's literally a carbon copy of his
videos
[Music]
[Applause]
come on
this room is the ultimate punishment for
prisoners so this is going to be really
hard I'm going to give you a tour this
is my bed it was a little distasteful
too nothing a little bit
I'm going to [ __ ] in this bucket like a
prisoner
[Laughter]
these [ __ ] scum live like rats
love that for him though yep bet I want
to look at more of his channel I'm kind
of down with it all phidius is his name
what are you looking at subscribe with
notifications on damn it
we'll do it Mr Beast copy two yes the
cookie thing
let's look at his top most viewed ones I
shook top 100 Youtubers hands okay let's
check it out why am I not on here the
handle of the biggest YouTuber because
it has always been my dream to meet them
in person and to make this more
challenging the hundredth one is going
to be my favorite Creator Mr Beast and
the only big YouTuber I know here in the
USA how many months you think this video
will take for me to feel I feel like
that
try boys
[Music]
oh hell no he's not one of the top the
11th biggest YouTuber Brad no no bro he
never asked my ass
[Music]
could have sold me an nft bro
I ran a half marathon Barefoot in the
snow and I got severe frostbite
no you didn't if you got severe Prospect
you would have lost your feet idiot
wait I just wait I closed that but I was
just more Curious now
all right that's that is funny
wait lost 100 pounds in 100 days
let's get this fat boy skinny
that [ __ ] is my friend pudgy where's 200
107 pounds
I want to help him go from 300 pounds to
200. now we put them in solitary
confinement that's how I did it it
starves them for a couple months that's
a lot if this is all your stuff this is
your new house you are going to live
with me I'm excited day one first time
to the gym how you feel tired tired of
walking the stairs up I will teach him
how to swim
I can't let him quit but I don't know
in the basket
say what I said day five put the lotion
in the basket
is that a Buffalo Bill referencing yeah
of weight oh my God you look
oh my God
you need to lose another 62 pounds in
six weeks man you were a stranger in the
beginning create your custom plan he was
a stranger just found some fat dude
oh
[Music]
I don't think so this stuff fits me
anymore it's just too big for me this
thing is yours
get on the skill fat Ben
take your shirt take your shirt off
Piggy
[Music]
was extremely hard for passion we are in
Vegas
we're here with pasha's favorite
creators and we're going to surprise him
away so wait let's find out did he lose
the weight
good for you Pasha after 100 days this
is the final weight let's see what you
did
spiders it's finally over for me
10.6 oh my God we failed
[Applause]
oh my God we failed oops well it was
still worth it this guy's like Mr
BEAST's uh
uh
it's like when you make Mr Beast mom
smoke crack when she was pregnant
it's so funny how we made a whole video
and then like literally the last second
nah all for nothing we failed we failed
we failed oh here's a good one most
homeless in the most dangerous place in
America Skid Row
oh no he's out in the Tent City in Skid
Row trading up like a playground yeah
dude this is a playground for him he's
gonna cosplay as a homeless person for
fun right now
to spend the next three days homeless in
Los Angeles with the last day being the
most dangerous Street Skid Row always
was trouble
social experience challenge it's not a
commercial experiment yeah those people
are [ __ ] bro it's not like a joke for
fun
it's not like a challenge this is the
same mentality where he's like I'm going
to the Portage country in Africa
and fighting off hordes of begging
children
this is Skid Row gang members he
actually stabbed a man in the head with
an ice pick firstly I came to this part
awesome bro yo this man was stabbed in a
head with a nice Peak
I'm going to stay where his body was
chopped out
it's so funny this is coming from Europe
just to check out the homeless people
yes coming from Cyprus to go live on the
streets in Skid Row L.A
this guy's awesome actually
already so crowded and he's going to
take up more space yeah yeah I'm going
to fight for a tent spot in Skid Row I
will threaten them with violence and
become king of the homeless don't worry
just like all of his other Challenge
videos he lasts two hours and yeah
it's just too hard out here homeless
people friends so in this park there is
a playground homeless people okay
some dumbass there's tents everywhere in
L.A that looks like a nice park while I
was exploring the park one non-profit
organization came to give food to the
homeless people and uh we focus on
providing mutualism
he took it fortune cookie
ah wait let me go back
oh he's taking the resource yeah what
the [ __ ] I went to Skid road to steal
from them
toothbrush I take three
[Laughter]
there's limited number of hot lunch I
take three they are so giving here
so generous
while I was exploring the park one
non-profit organization came to give
food to the home why did he take a
fortune code what kind of lunch is that
toothbrush while I was exploring the
park one non-profit organization came to
give food to the [ __ ]
why a fortune cookie
to the homeless people and we focus on
providing Mutual Aid maybe inside
there'll be luck for me in the fortune
cookie uh Rehabilitation and temporary
housing to the unhoused and underserved
in the Los Angeles community
this kind lady paid for my hotel
it was great I got I got the last bet in
the homeless shelter yes yes oh God
three days I will try to experience
homelessness as well and I will go to
different streets different parts and
the Heritage to live in ski
throws she's like that's
stupid bro you're making a mockery of
what we're doing why you are laughing
when I said about you see one day you'll
be laughing with me
this is Clinton my new friend here that
will show me around he lives here in
this path so Clinton robbed me oh he
found a homeless friend
he sure did this is my buddy Clinton
he will show to me the park
we are going to show us around it's like
a follow-up clothes myself my own
workout clothes later we can play some
basketball together it depends how much
game you got if I beat you can I stay
inside yeah I'll sleep outside they
don't do nothing people here today he's
taking his test he hung out in the park
and they chill and they just passed time
with empty pockets and empty schedules
and
kind of in survival mode I as I
understand I don't want to be in
survival mode because then that's my way
of life I'm just here
they sleep inside that car keep
forgetting
my friend did you miss me yes I did I
didn't even know you were here buddy
they invited me in their backpack to
there I am having a appreciate it thank
you so it wasn't horrible I feel like
it's just the concept of the video
itself
kind of like the other one like the
thumbnail yeah yeah I'm curious where it
goes though
let's see oh it just started yeah I
didn't realize we're not done I know you
will
[Music]
like there's not a genuine moment it's
all Mr Bean style I feel I feel like
we've been watching like an intro for
five minutes yeah yeah it's just all
action-packed homeless Skid Row vibes
uh having fun this is good stuff he peed
on himself this man peed on himself oh
boy
um there's a really good Channel called
Soft White underbelly where they
interview people from skid row and I
think that that's a very good Channel
I've seen those those are fantastic
they're really great really incredible
insight into the humans condition there
this poor man pitted on himself a few of
the people who would come into the
needle exchange I've seen them on that
channel oh
yeah no I've seen those good wrote those
that that shit's great yeah because the
the reality is it's just really tragic
and these are not these aren't like bad
people they're criminals these are
people who don't have any support in
their life who are mentally ill or who
are drug addicts and probably usually a
combination of more than one of those
things and it's just a tragic failing of
society that we have no support for them
this man think a piece [ __ ] in his pants
we live in a society he is thinking the
whole bench we move our tent
himself oh miss you
why this man peace himself he's kind of
old fun all together he's half so he
went to bring his gun
I know you will
I'm not challenging you or nothing like
that we are going to fight
there's no way that would have happened
this is happening in the safest Park I
wonder what is going to happen in
Skittle this man will be gone in a bed I
wonder
the way he edits it to like the skid row
font in all red popping up across the
screen
yeah it's awesome this is a good ass
content to be honest it's like stick
figures with guns uh yeah oh this is a
reenactment of the uh fight
you have a blessing let's get rolled man
good night Clinton I will make my bed
now this is the place that I will stay
today it was interesting day tomorrow it
will be more interesting and ski throw
would be extremely interesting well if
you go with that
expectation
then you're probably
yeah you know good morning uh what the
[ __ ] dude you're just filming people
passed out
here's a man passed out on the floor
we like we we walk by him this he smell
like cheese
[ __ ] these pants
[Music]
what kind of shot is this bro it's just
been [ __ ] up
[ __ ] up dude
this man is [ __ ] himself we like we
we filmed it
he says this is the most important video
I've ever made that's what he said and
then he links to become a member
no there's no charity aspect to this by
the way
which is kind of Awesome
Skid Row is one of the most dangerous
places in America a homeless problem in
La is getting bigger and bigger that's
why I decided to go out and explore this
place myself to see if the stories were
real
it's awesome there's no charity aspect
yeah he didn't even shout out the uh
non-profit right right
good point but like just you're filming
this we tried to work out a sponsorship
deal with them and they weren't playing
balls yeah yeah they didn't give them
enough free food yeah bro you just
filmed like a [ __ ] passed out
homeless person and you ain't even doing
[ __ ] to help them
they have plenty of food because people
come here and bring food every day we
take the food from the nice people
saying turns out it's not that bad
there's plenty of food so it's nice
I learned so much stuff about different
aspects in the life here so when you get
called the problem enough you start to
feel like the problem right actually
what he said it's very interesting
because that's the only insight
and his whole night
spending with these people if everybody
thinks that you are the problem you kind
of starting feeling like you are the
problem let's be a pleasure thank you
for being nice to me
[Music]
I left the pot you know he's like all
right can you guys just do the shop for
me where we all hug real fast I'll give
you five bucks
probably didn't give him [ __ ] I Gotta Go
My doordash is almost at my my Mansion
so uh we could just grab the shot real
quick I don't know it kind of feel I
kind of feel like this could have been
good because yeah he seemingly actually
went out there and slept there all night
that's kind of respectable so if you
actually made a good story about this
and not like [ __ ] Hunger Games yeah I
could have been good and totally if he
actually like focused on the human
aspect instead of like here's a passed
out bum and this man pissed himself
like Mr B's style of action Cuts it's
just not the vibe but it's I'm enjoying
it two three buses to the train station
three bus these people are waiting for
the train and I will show you something
interesting this Metro that is going to
come I see a lot of people sleeping in
the train why they do this why you do
this why you sleep on the train I have
no place to go this is not a pleasant
image we found some [ __ ] on the floor of
the of the metro and the man he's
sleeping the sheets
um
people come here because it's more safe
to stay here in the Metro station a lot
of homeless people how they make money
they collect a lot of trash cans and
they love that they collecting the trash
give them to a place that they give them
money to buy it cash baby
alcohol and wheat do you know anything
about Skid Row yeah it's uh the place
try not to do there too long you know
whatever you do just don't it don't
don't show no fear there is some beauty
in meeting strangers I don't know what I
like about it but it's yeah
I mean just laying their [ __ ] and film
them it's disgusting but beautiful
and a place to stay tonight and tomorrow
I'm going to ski throw oh my God what
you know about skid row it's a horrible
place and the problem is that many
people
tomorrow the night and all day there you
think it will be dangerous it's
dangerous anything we do Santa Monica by
the way he noticed he thinks
Santa Monica if the guy goes anything we
do is nowhere near Skid Row lead officer
side of town you know what I've seen in
Coming to America and he goes hello my
neighbor and they go [ __ ] you [ __ ] you
too yes but they reminded me of Santa
Monica thank you
the wrong way go and spend tomorrow the
night and all day there you think it
will be dangerous it's dangerous
anything we do by the way he's saying
like as a homeless person anything would
do is dangerous he's like not for me I'm
a tourist he has no clue what he's doing
he is so fun this is this is just a fun
oh I'm not homeless I'm just doing a fun
little uh sleepover
Santa Monica beautiful Santa Monica the
antithesis of skittless and gentlemen do
I look homeless or no not really I don't
do a good job
what is a homeless person supposed to
look like [ __ ] face do I need to cover
for more dirt on my face
maybe some needle marks [ __ ] my pants
[Music]
in the bathroom bro
you can't do that that's
illegal oh come on that's like actually
straight up illegal
wait just enjoy this scene
he's in the bathroom be like I'm
recording
I don't do a good job
watch the [ __ ] Santa Monica Pier toilet
I'm peeing while recording hey guys
[Applause]
bro I'm not taking a pause to pee I'm
filming you're taking a piss very dirty
and I want to jump inside the ocean to
clean my body and I will do this now
you can't imagine how much I enjoyed the
other side
taking a bath in the ocean is that's
probably the grossest way to clean
yourself in it
I mean you should you should shower
after going in the ocean they have
showers there right yeah that might have
been a better so guys
who I am in 10 seconds okay I um
what happened on the concept of this
video he threw it out the window dude
the Santa Monica is titled
spending time in Skid Row right
he's getting there I mean we're we're
more than halfway through based off the
progress bar like cabinet and we're just
like having a day it's at Hong Kong
Beach she's just chilling just a vlog
now yeah so so wait he's describing you
can't imagine how much I enjoyed the
other side so guys I will try to explain
you who I am in 10 seconds okay I am
happy discipline I'm not organized a bit
boring I work all time and that's it
about me okay good
have a great day
I get the feeling Mr Beast was like you
want your videos to be around 14 minutes
right and there's just so much extra
content in here that doesn't need to be
I tell you who I am okay you have to
know some stuff about me that's why I
did fit Sun is going down and I'm going
to marry that girl she laughed so oh
Jesus bro cat calling now
oh the goal is to go to Walmart and I
don't spend money on materials
yeah okay
do you know I'm looking for people that
sleep in their cars okay well guess
we're one of them
I like your personality yeah thank you
we go sleep in the mountains this is
Daniel
extremely tired and tonight I have to
sleep outside
and I don't have nothing more than this
so now I came to one part that I saw in
the map to survive here tonight I always
wanted to sleep inside the kid
why are you sleeping on a kid's
playground
dude he's always wanted to do this
don't [ __ ] with the kids playground
just go sleep on the grass you first
prerogative
kids are going to want to play there
tomorrow dude
God damn it's my bed for the night I
stole this from a homeless person he
was from a homeless person
bro you bad you better stop wait wait
let's watch that again I always wanted
to sleep inside the kid playground so
this is my bed for the night I stole
this from a homeless person
but I would put it back in the morning I
went in bro this just gets worse and
worse it really is we've abandoned the
entire reason for the video in the first
place I killed the man for this classic
videos this man was passed out any [ __ ]
I stole his bed out here it's either be
eaten God someone said I show speed just
showed Minecraft p word live on stream
p word oh yes Dan p word
p-o-r-n we can't say that word I don't
know I'm not
you guys made fun of me when I asked
that the other day p word
I'm just trying to be stupid
our last two videos were demonetized are
claimed yeah
um will rip to his channel I guess oh we
have got a comment from bulla saying not
so much peace and love this is the worst
episode you've ever done you're
profiting off of all this disappointing
I didn't make the video I'm just
watching it what the [ __ ] I'm just
watching no one is allowed to shake
these people no one allows is allowed to
be Cricket yeah no you can't be critical
of a giant YouTuber this video I know
Jesus get out of here
tell hid that I didn't make the [ __ ]
video
oh yeah you deleted it
and erase the message yeah [ __ ] with Dan
by the way somehow oh we got 50 gifted
subs from
no way I really
I really want to do a segment called
stupid comment of the week or like our
favorite comment of the of the week I
swear I've been pushing for it forever
it would just be great if you see some
write them down if you see something say
something okay
like the meanest comments no no just the
dumbest stupid [ __ ] comment of the
day yeah and then we'll just we could
all have our favorite highlighter I have
a bunch by the way thank you Mary for
the uh modest tithing and thank you to
the Saudi uh royalty for the 50 gifts
yes
what is that's the real call back to the
beginning of the episode that's the real
reason that you're gentle
on uh oh yeah talk about it yeah our
Saudi benefactors
um well I just don't understand what the
[ __ ] do you want dude and you're a
member so I love and appreciate you but
like what the [ __ ] sooner great episode
all day street vibes love when you all
do games there you go thank you sooner
and they've been a member for 23 months
it was uh I was happy with these uh
episode until you showed him in with
these [ __ ] on the floor
I didn't do it it was him write that to
him what the [ __ ] did I do
like how do you watch the show for any
period of time and be surprised that
we're watching cringy content and
criticizing it like this is the bread
and butter of the History Podcast yes
like 95 of people maybe more are saying
yes do that segment there's a few people
saying no those few people might want to
check yourself because I'm guessing
they're gonna be one of them or you have
left a message hi Dan
[Applause]
someone says this is a wonderful show
but I definitely a picture which parts
are going to get clipped to cancel Ethan
what the [ __ ] come on I'm not this isn't
worse than any other cancel you're the
worst I didn't make this video and we're
saying it I'm saying it's bad that's the
[ __ ] up
all right let's continue
God
brought this sleeping bag because I'm
very cold one person worked in the park
we started shouting to me I'm a bit
afraid now to sleep here with that guy
I'm not gonna lie he's like the guy was
screaming give me back my sleeping bag
it's a little Discovery out there and
the police helicopter is going around
all the time worst case scenario he I
don't know I don't care about him I'm so
tired that I want to sleep good night
good morning it's kid throw away I took
this is it a problem I'm sorry that's
okay no problem dude what the [ __ ] he
actually stole [ __ ] from this guy you
might be wondering oh my God even
yeah included the guy he he burglarized
night good morning it's kid throw away I
took this is it a problem I'm sorry
that's okay no problem you might be
wondering why I'm going to see the
internet of a problem with it he's been
sleeping on the streets yeah where was
she sleeping yeah
into church so today it's sister in my
religion I grew up in a religious family
I kind of like it going to church and
praying now next stop is my house cool
just to live during the homeless video
now next stop my house awesome the
camera so Skid Row people doesn't rob me
these are the only things I'm taking
with me I hope they don't steal them
I'm coming but I hope they don't steal
it wait whoa whoa whoa [ __ ] you're the
one [ __ ] stealing their [ __ ] I hope
these dirty homeless people don't steal
my stuff oh I'll just yoink that's mine
now oh dude it's bad way to be
anti-homeless in the video where you're
trying to raise awareness about
homelessness we take you can take from
the homeless as long as you give it back
yeah
it's not stealing I give him in the
morning oh my God by the way it's just
crazy how he acting like I am off to
Disneyland baby let's get is this
exciting
people doesn't rob me these are the only
things I'm taking with me I hope they
don't steal them
us is not exactly it's going to make a
trip to Vegas he's going to ace Fest yes
I hope they don't rob me here I am here
I am
self-sove scene yo if he really wants to
fit in I want I got to see him shooting
up heroin yeah let's let's see how much
you really want to fit in down there boy
it's going all out what you see in the
movies this bus is going to take me to
Skid Row the moment of truth
I love the action movie music too
this is dangerous by the way skid wrote
during the day is not oh love that's not
that bad
um I mean I mean you've been still
occupied it's still entire like the the
sidewalks are entirely occupied by tents
I mean I definitely want to walk there
at night that's for sure
would you say
hobophobia yeah
that's maybe that this is what Kim
we this whole time we thought he was
just an idiot and he misspoke uh he
hates homeless phobia he's acting like
he's going to Chernobyl right now
yeah
this is
one person here and he told me be very
careful who you talk to thank you for
the food
you cannot speak no
okay you can't hear good but you cannot
fall how old are you sir
I am 21.
[Music]
sometimes look at this [ __ ] guy
this shot look at these [ __ ] freak
out here
just a little action shot look at these
[ __ ] man keep low profile soap people
don't understand what I'm doing what's
the scariest thing that you saw here oh
mask how many years you are here 49 are
commuted to other cities but I live here
you like this place yeah I like this
place do you have any advice for me that
I will sleep here just keep quiet and
try and and get along with whoever you
leaked on the street this car just
stopped by and he dropped some clothes
they gave me as well
no this is my bag he's saying that he's
on his back but I'm still in the
sleeping bag that he gave me bro why you
keep taking [ __ ] from them
he took a sleeping bag he's like yo I
need that back he's like hell no [ __ ]
this is my bag
[Music]
sir did you lost anything come on what
yes
the beach I heard a lot of Sir what the
[ __ ] are you doing
bad things that can happen to me Boris
boring someone said Borat X Mr Beast
the chat's been spamming that for a
while that's [ __ ] awesome a great
success this is degrees tell me why are
you playing with your [ __ ]
very nice
that white and young is not a good
combination people will try to mess with
me in the night I didn't feel kind of
safe and found a place to stay I'm a bit
scared you've been here for how many
years going on 41 years this May 15th oh
my God you can call this place uh
survival Zone this is like a cry for
help area we're all human you came out
here because something in you pulled you
and only those who are pulled and
interested
will make the difference don't introduce
yourself with silly measures of one
night sleeping around here don't put
yourself in danger
that guy's speaking the truth
smartest person don't be a dumbass and
come sleep here for a night this is our
life bro that guy's lived there 41 years
it's not a little [ __ ] video for you
silly measures of one night sleeping
around here don't put yourself in
dangers you don't need to beat it
because it's only peaceful to those who
are aware of the Sun is going down and
things are about to get Daria he's like
thanks for the advice but the pop off
baby
he's like yo listen bro take it from
someone who's lived here this is stupid
don't stay here for a night it wouldn't
[ __ ] you but anyway
thanks for the advice you were homeless
piece of [ __ ]
[Music]
addiction of drugs in the night it's a
different story that we are going to
experience together
oh my God I am
Guru all day I've been filming and
people understood that I am not homeless
so people are passing by me and they're
saying don't get too comfortable and
they're shouting to me and I feel a bit
unsafe here probably people are telling
me to leave or I'll die but but the
challenge I stay you can see how big his
light is in the reflection of his eyes
totally it's so [ __ ] bright
Pleasant try to find different spots
well also there's probably people doing
a lot of legal [ __ ] and they don't love
uh a camera right walking around
everywhere for sure like yo we're trying
to do drugs and [ __ ] and you're filming
bruh
what is the toilet with the security 24
7. oh you're sleeping next to the
security you [ __ ] I will set my stuff
here in this corner if I sleep people
will come and wrap my phone so one get a
shouting but this is very normal here
[Music]
which they can't do anything for their
medication that's a major problem here
but it's been one of the most beautiful
experiences oh shut up
before I got jumped don't even [ __ ]
say that Slayer
of my life doing this video so I'm
really grateful I slept for eight hours
there and nobody bothered me
five a.m and I will take a walk around
to see what is going on I think I was so
very reacting all the night because I
heard all these stories and I believe in
5 a.m there is not much going on here
good morning sir the sun started coming
out another one hour to go until the sun
comes up and I finally finish it's been
successfully the night on Skid Row oh my
God he literally did it
Yahoo Yahoo
and he's like [ __ ] you I'm out of here
I love that he didn't give anyone money
the homeless people money no charitable
organizations it's a different time on
YouTube
[ __ ] You Skid Row
up yours walk more or less
oops I might not have 10 000 to give you
to subscribe like Mr Beast but I put all
my effort into creativity why give money
to them you just stop [ __ ]
he said he didn't have money I know but
it's like he's like if I had money I
give it to you guys not the them
YouTube videos
subscribe you're in the middle of the
street idiot there you have it guys
super uplifting the most beautiful uh
experience of his life thing I've seen
today I didn't plan on uh
watching this no that was impromptu but
uh that was pretty incredible
maybe he's got uh something he wants us
to watch a little comparison this is one
of my favorite H3 clips of all time oh
an H3 clip yeah
when you're feeding the homeless video
oh yeah well that was a that was a trend
at the time yeah right everybody was
making those videos like I remember
there was one guy
he would like wake people up while they
were sleeping give him like a cookie or
something this is him
in this video let me go back the person
behind the size of his enormous head
oh yeah this is the guy who's talking
yeah yeah bro I had interactions with a
guy he would email me all the time and
beg me to remove these videos oh because
he was he's like a magician trying to
make it big in like Hollywood what was
his name
he had he had stuff most [ __ ] up video
where he was like basically just
essaying women on campus
and then he erased it he's like please
dude I've learned and then
actually I try to do a massage and I
took his name out of the title in the
description I was like this I'm not
gonna erase him Daniel Fernandez yeah
Daniel Fernandez I'm not gonna erase it
but I'll take your name out of the title
and description and meta and meta keys
and he just kept emailing me like bro
you gotta help me out dude that feeding
the homeless video [ __ ] up I love this
look at this
hey Daniel's like I'm gonna talk to him
in a language he understands hey
[Laughter]
I love this he poured like one dollar of
change in his [ __ ] he's eating that
food Daniel you poured coffee
he's eating there man the guy's like man
you just ruined my meal it was worth
more than the amount of change his words
[Music]
yeah and the slow-mo's I hope the music
doesn't get claimed I don't think this
video ever got claimed
I could be wrong about that
editing you don't get that song you
don't get that slow-mo for giving
someone 95 cents and by the way ruining
your meal Daniel the only reason you
play that music is so that you can feel
like a god so that you can feel like a
saint okay and by the way you are you're
very handsome by the way and I wouldn't
mind seeing you naked but that's another
story what kill bro at uh three minutes
and 30 seconds does the Vitali clip
which is also gold oh the Vitaly one you
know Vitali is my favorite because you
know he doesn't give a single [ __ ] about
the homeless and he can't even hide it
in his own feeding the homeless video
yeah the skid row used to be like
stomping ground for like these pseudo
YouTube uh humanitarians you do to make
them look good we got enough for
everybody this is not the only box this
is not the only box can you get in line
I gotta go get more context because this
[ __ ] is awesome Vitali was definitely my
favorite yeah so niceness about it and
they didn't seem forced at all until
Vitale made his homeless video that
thing's got a little weird
yeah he left that in I mean how much of
a piece of [ __ ] was he yeah the whole
time that that was the most benevolent
clip yeah that was the good take and
that music was the music he was playing
story of my life back up
homeless videos actually had a genuine
business about it and they didn't seem
forced at all it wasn't until Vitale
made his homeless video that things got
a little weird can you guys
can you guys back okay now what I love
about this video is that the music the
sweet and cheery music betrays what's
actually going on in the scene let's
take a closer look at what's actually
happening in this video we got enough
for everybody we got enough for everyone
we've got enough for everyone I'm
freaking out
no no no [ __ ] back up everyone just
keep watching
Everybody all right stop stop
no positive language at all
this video he made had like tens of
millions of views like so generous
beautiful music stop no
oh [ __ ] oh my God stop killing me it's
[ __ ] rude as hell stop let's put that
in stop you know what this means it just
means that this is the best footage wow
it's like I have the same brain as this
guy I'm making the same joke
2015. wow oh man seven years ago bro
dude
that's crazy times of change on YouTube
though now YouTube has go to a skid row
to take from the homeless instead of uh
they had to step up their game
that little stop is better for me than
the loud stop stop after the spring it's
so aggressive it's so personal
behave
yeah totally govern yourself accordingly
yes
where he wasn't tripping out and yelling
at everyone the stop was the best they
could do to make him look good we got
enough for everybody this is not the
only box this is not the only box can
you get in line
for everybody just back up
can you got look at look at what you're
doing
we've got enough for everybody
how hungry are you sons of [ __ ] back
up
[Music]
everyone's screaming and [ __ ] this is
supposed to make me feel good it makes
me terrified it makes me ashamed to be a
human being
just watch this part just watch this guy
we got enough sandwiches for everybody
foreign
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
music over and it's a [ __ ] viral hit
I love that this whole thing could have
been diffused if he just allowed someone
else to hand the sandwiches out with him
but because he's so obsessed with being
the one person that hands out each
thousand sandwich you just create this
huge chaotic butt [ __ ] fest dude now I
can't hate on the guy for giving away a
bunch of sandwiches he did a really nice
thing in a really dangerous part of town
but I think it's the first video I saw
where it's like there's something a
little bit going on here more than the
sandwich the disconnect from like what
you're supposed to yeah anyway
pretty great I mean really shout out to
Vitality when did you say that video was
20 October 15th October 2015 or 2015.
okay yeah I was 14 years old when I
watched that video
and now I'm here
I was gonna say I started watching your
channel right around then yeah the first
video I ever saw was the Fine Brothers
video and that was I just looked it up
as beginning of 2016 so yeah right
around then this was like one of the
First videos I'd show people if I was
trying to introduce them to H3 that's
nice yeah that was like Peak uh H3 era
and it's crazy to think it was seven
years ago we're we're peaked now
well we're the history publishing a
podcast
product HP Productions is dead baby
it's dead
oh my God so shout out to uh Mr Beast
protege
videos
for bravely and boldly going to Skid Row
stealing a
a sleeping bag you really did that
feeling of sleeping mat a sandwich
taking the yeah taking the donations for
making people notation recording in the
bathroom going to sleep for some reason
it was just kind of a detour I'm gonna
go to Santa Monica for yeah and check
out this video Santa Monica and and for
filming OD'd people human feces
introduce people to himself as
discipline yes yes yes true she's
disciplined kind and kind very true
okay generous and the guy's like okay
and what man
prove it
he had like little drum rolls
there too when he was saying that he's
like discipline kind
happy and finally
and finally the best not the best uh I
love the part where he tried heroin that
was my favorite dude he's a [ __ ] you
know cow
if he wasn't such a coward he would have
smoked crap
like you yeah like me I've done that
yeah more Skid Row than he'll ever be
that's right or maybe I put it another
way or a bunch of [ __ ] thank you Rudy
uh thank you baloney for five gifted
Subs
[Applause]
cribe
should we do this um I guess it's pretty
late no we should wrap it up because we
got a lot of prep to do for leftovers
tomorrow yeah
I'm happy to be back but I'm also I just
uh
getting up in the morning
once a week come on yeah so we'll be
back tomorrow morning with uh Hassan for
an episode of leftovers by the way past
I want to do this dude perfect sponsored
video of Qatar on Friday okay yeah it
sounds good we'll note that but anyway
thanks for watching guys we'll see you
in the morning for an episode of
leftovers obviously
so much to discuss yeah
and uh shout out to everyone watching
and Skid Row shoot one up for me
still a sleeping bag for me eh
and uh well that's about it so thank you
everybody
's incline the winner of smell my funker
congratulations again that's right
I've got the super schnags
happy birthday Dan tomorrow's your
birthday right Dan uh right and more
importantly
Cameron today wait Cam's birthday but
yours is when my birthday's tomorrow
no it's just I know you said that
because love put a note but he he
immediately edited to say cam because he
meant to say cam but I know happy
birthday
tomorrow
and a 50
50 uh gift donation from our Saudi
Prince audio sadio
audios audio
[Applause]
all right guys we'll see you tomorrow
morning maybe go watch uh Monday's
episode oh is it fixed all right do you
want to find out together right now yeah
yeah yeah because it should refresh
and
drumroll please
thank you here we go here we go and the
results are in and yeah
wait this is today's episode right wrong
one hold on the results are in this
episode is too late too yeah uh I've got
terrible news it's still not working
meanwhile on Facebook
the Facebook video well great open it in
two browsers yo that's the way it is
yeah that's and double the views should
be working well my friends oh yeah but
it's really worked the views are
fantastic
yeah we should just more often going on
there
well we did have audio issues today so
maybe we'll be blessed by the uh audio
God
all right everybody have a good night
see you tomorrow morning
Tata from the host and winner of
smell my bunker